all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things youtube channel today
is episode 5 of the pre-game
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell you already know the
deal if you have watched two or more of
my lives
and you don't subscribe okay
me you we have beef all right beef so
hit that subscribe button
also before i start we have a sponsor
for the stream today it is
cooking with chris so he offers
comp hold on let me read it
completely custom made meal plans plans
that allow you to eat delicious food
while being your healthiest self so
guys if you buy one of these meal plans
it actually supports the show and we're
trying to raise money for mics and and
i'm on this meal plan and i'm down six
pounds in two weeks so yeah
i know i know
i'm trying to get slimmer less thick
um yeah so consider that the link to
that is in the description
okay so today's topic is do women
secretly prefer men who cheat
and before i start i'm going to have
everybody go around and introduce
themselves
so starting with our special guest i am
sarah gabi um
social commentator
professional
feather ruffler sometimes
it seems um
and
yeah very opinionated individual
hi if you've seen any of pearl's other
podcasts you know who i am sorry i'm
jess
nice to see you guys again um
yeah
also wait put in your age and your
relationship status put that in oh
um
i'm 40 years old
and i'm
single i am 27 years old and
so would that be complicated
in between
[Music]
hi i'm abby
i'm single i'm 24.
okay
uh hi i'm eileen i'm
24 as well and i'm complicated
okay guys if you guys want to follow any
of their platforms all of their links
are in the description so i put all of
your instagrams in so
and youtube channels for the two of you
okay so
the
first question we have and we're gonna
go around everyone answer it
have you ever been cheated on and did
you take that person back
um i've been cheated on
and
i
it's complicated um i didn't necessarily
take them back but we had a child
together so we were living together
so we were together
but not together in the same house
if that makes sense so
yeah
but you know i eventually left but
yeah i've been cheated on
but it was a weird situation but in that
moment did you take her back when she
told you like did you let it go or like
no i do don't let it go no no okay no no
not at all in any way shape or form how
did you find out
um i found out
from
so crazy i
i found out because i found a letter
in i was doing washing one day
and i was emptying pockets of um
you know as you do
and there was a letter in her dressing
gown and it was to this dude
and i was like
what
and um
yeah it was
it was a revelation because we were
engaged
and um
yeah
it was crazy trust me how long was it
going on before you found out i think
probably about two years two years she
was having an affair for about two years
with this guy she never told you the
full story um
she never told me the full story no i
had to find out the full story
um so it was like yeah from then it's
just like
there's nothing else to do
it's time to go
[Music]
yeah
i forgot to turn off the boots
well um
have i been cheated
on um
i have a like a speculation that i have
been but to my knowledge no no
confirmation
no but it's weird my
first relationship i was in
we broke up and then two months later
this person is getting married and i'm
like
so explain to me
you were cheating
how you break up with somebody
and then
two months later he was engaged while he
was seeing you yeah i i put the puzzle
pieces together and i was like all right
[ __ ] happens charge it to the game yeah
but i broke up with him so it really
doesn't matter
maybe it could have been you like at the
aisle you didn't break up
how long were you together not long not
long ago okay
no not no
yeah not even long no did you ever think
about messaging the girl
no because i could care less about him
not at all because that's never gonna
happen
yeah
i was cheated on i think that was my
first relationship
um he called me on the way to a girl's
house
but i didn't i didn't take him back i
kind of cut off immediately hang on he
called you as his and it was so childish
as he's about to go and cheat on you
yeah but it was like it was petty
because
i'm a [ __ ] this girl right
is that what he did he was like he was
18 i was like 15
no 16 at the time
um and i wasn't willing to obviously
engage in sexual activities at the time
and then i think he called me like he
was pissed off
no i was 15 i'll do my mocks
oh you were young like you were young
yeah you you're doing your marks you
were young
and then i think he called me in like he
was trying to and i was like no i'm
focused on my mocks
and then he went elsewhere and i was
like that's fine like do your thing
and then he i think try to like
he was like oh let's be friends i was
like no like we're done and then he
tried to get back in after i was like no
like you actually called me on the way
and then wait he called me after he left
the girls house and was like
you know she was good
what did you say on podcast yeah you
could tell i was like he was like you
know like i fingered her
like we did this with that and i was
like okay why is he telling me
can i just say adding on to my phone
cycle on my house phone my dad answered
passes me the phone and he's like
okay cool i've left her house i fingered
her i did this i did that i'm like okay
like i'm trying to focus on walks like
the mocks are you'll put it to grace
weird wait what are mocks first of all
okay mock exams
yeah
yeah what she said so i was just like
okay
um and then i was just done but i was
done with it because i was like do you
know who i am
so yeah i was done with it i didn't take
them back so outside of then have you
ever been cheated on you mentioned the
toxic x which one was that the same one
oh it's a different one yeah but he
wasn't toxic because he physically
cheated on me
so i i'll never assume that like it's
not even my concern the toxic one yeah
yeah i love how we keep saying that
sorry
i mean she's not working
out
yeah like i feel like emotionally he
probably like he did cheat like those
messages
but physically i have no proof
okay yeah okay
what about you um
yeah definitely been cheated on
um i would say that was like my first
serious relationship it was like
but i was also really really young um so
he was a senior in high school
i was a sophomore
um so like
big it's a lot kind of a long story long
story short he is like um from korea but
he's been studying and he has like
perfect english whatever but this girl
from korea came to come see him
i guess like for his graduation
and he's like oh no like it's just a
friend i'm like hey no it doesn't seem
like a friend if she's coming all the
way there from there to come to your
graduation like what is this and then
i'm like okay whatever i'll just let it
go believe him and then i'm like at this
volleyball tournament in san francisco
and my friend messaged me oh i see him
holding like hands with this girl
like oh like they're like very touchy
and everything i'm like no [ __ ] way
i call him no answer called his friend
no answer called him like 10 i like went
full on psycho
i called him multiple times and then
like finally at the end he was like yeah
that happened i'm like okay
cool
so did you break up with him after did
you take him back so i actually did
take him back okay but i would say like
why
i would think i was just like
crazy but so like after i took him back
though i did break up with him after
you were crazy would you mean what was
that like i think i was just like so
like i thought i was so like in love
with him right okay that everything like
my emotions just overcame like what is
it my like common sense right basically
but in the end i like thought about it
longer and then eventually like a month
later i broke up and like cut off all
contact with him
like no reasoning just completely cut
off right
was that the only time that's happened
yes
are you going to answer the question
yeah it's going to go okay
[Applause]
why are you laughing because i know this
story and i love this this well i don't
know if the second one i don't love it
sorry no no i don't know if that one
counts though because we we weren't
actually together okay you know what i'm
saying
all right i'll okay i guess i'll oh
gosh there's a long history going on
here this is this is the problem with
people knowing whom i'm so sorry um but
okay what's your real story then no it
was um
i found something over the summer but i
didn't have actually like
it was more like
something he was like
gonna do
but didn't actually like do to my
knowledge but i feel like the planning
is like it's not full-on cheating but
it's like right it's a little bit of a
betrayal that's what that's exactly
that's exactly how i felt so he didn't
cheat he was planning on cheating
yeah and then i found out about it
before you done it yeah
premeditated
um
um let's just say he was still logged in
on something and i just had like a
feeling
so you went snooping
yeah i did okay
yeah because we we had like a really big
like fight
like two days before and i hadn't talked
to him in like two days so it was like
the i don't know and i was like what is
he doing
yeah and i was like
i think he's yeah so
so then
yeah and then i like kind of went crazy
a little bit so
yeah details see when women say that
right oh one that crazy like what does
that mean i went crazy a little bit i
think it means that we do we like did
things that we
would never do if screaming crying like
yeah did you smash anything did you no
no i didn't i don't i don't have that in
me no i just i just went like
i just felt like i went over like i just
went over there and just started like
screaming and like crying and just being
like what and then i got back from a day
later
like that yeah
i don't know in my head i like justified
it because he didn't actually like do it
that i know you know
that i know of so like in my head i was
like well he didn't actually like
running but like yeah like i don't know
if he actually was gonna do it and then
like i was like it could have just been
like a thought you know
i i'm not saying like that was smart or
wise but that's just the way i thought
about it so when i said crazy what were
you
um
i look crazy what
um so i would say like no one heard that
go on um
like i literally like contacted him on
almost everything
and then just non-stop like calling
calling calling calling calling
then like basically when he did pick up
i was screaming at him i was like what
the [ __ ] do you think you're doing like
basically like you know i don't i feel
like like i would never
act like that normally i feel like yeah
anytime i act out of character i would
it's like say i'm acting crazy yeah
but that is your character then you
think so yeah because if it's not in you
it can't come out of you
i guess
i mean
like do you not
so do not think that if like something
were to happen to you like you can
act some sort of way that
like you wouldn't normally act unless
you're in that you know specific
situation like you're just your emotions
are like to the max your stress levels
to the max like you know that it just
pushes you to a certain level i would
say i guess you could still say like i
acted how i would
if i was in that situation
like
i probably would actually like that
yeah
yeah like what you said maybe you didn't
know it was you like you had it in you
you found out about yourself that day
yeah
maybe you realize like
wow that's who i am yeah i think women
get to act crazy
you think we get to you get to there's
more of a um
leniency with you acting crazier than
men acting crazy because if a man acts
crazy it's like what the [ __ ] like
i have dated an emotional night like
yeah but do you think that's do you
think that's because
women are seen to be these like
emotional
creatures yeah yeah but but that's some
it's one of those double standards isn't
it because like i know women that have
like smashed people's cars
you know like done all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] and it's like women going crazy if
a man wants to smash a woman's car
like people be like oh my god this guy
is [ __ ] toxic he's like
you know i mean like he's getting like
looked at in this in a different way
than women would yeah i agree with that
actually yeah i think girls are given
more of a past thing yeah it's very
crazy stuff but yeah i feel like that's
like the there's like a pro and con of
being men or women and so like you know
obviously being women i guess we get to
be a little more emotional whereas men
they get to be like more
what is it
um
going
what what are you gonna say no i
i won't say that um women aren't
emotional but i think
men
are emotional it just shows a little
differently and i think the reason why
women may have a little bit more
leniency towards their emotion is
because
if a man is say if a man smashed
somebody's car the next thought that
they're gonna think like what are they
gonna do to me right it's just like a
fearful tactic because we've seen we
haven't seen any women um the first
thing that comes to my mind is football
player in the states he literally picked
up this woman i don't know if it was
wife girlfriend or whatever and like
drag like threw her across the room like
she was a rag doll
so it's just like things like that i
think comes like to mind when a man
acts
their emotion is at that level to where
it's like crazy the thing is i've seen a
man do that to a woman but i've seen a
man do that to a woman
after she has
spat in his face
slapped him in his face
and been like what the [ __ ] are you
gonna do you can't do [ __ ] but and i'm
like
just that physical action of him doing
that
will in the general public's eyes make
him seem like the bad guy and people
will kind of negate
what she done yeah do you know i mean
like i'm saying women get to act crazy
and if a man responds to it it's like oh
look at him it's like did you not see
all the [ __ ]
before it actually happened i don't i
don't like when women do that because
i'm like
i don't like men hitting women but it's
like you've put yourself in that
position like if if a woman if you did
that to a woman she would react
retaliate the same way but you do that
to a man so when a man react retaliates
that same way you want to be like you
shouldn't hit women well don't don't
give him that lead way to retaliate in
that way because you don't know what's
inside a person to put them in that
position
right
i agree
no one should be hitting anyone at all
no one should be hearing like whoever
hits me i'm hitting them back i'm
rocking
real hard and if you hit a man no a man
can hit you back you know it's just that
simple do you guys agree with that
if you if you punch a guy like he can
punch you back yeah i mean i feel like
that's just like completely unfair if
like women are just like
i don't know what are these other men
supposed to just stand there like yeah
take it how are they supposed to process
their emotions like just sit there and
be like
and that's why that's why a lot of men
don't actually report domestic abuse
towards them
because they know it's not going to be
taken seriously it's like a woman hit
you what what were you gonna say it's
like no but you know there are a lot of
women out here
out there
actually physically abusing men and men
are taking it because they kind of know
that
it's not going to be taken seriously
that does bring up like you know like
the johnny dub case
yeah what happened i don't know that
case so what was that actress's name
i forget her name but i remember the
recordings it was just like
yeah
she um
i think she was just like abusive
mentally and physically towards him
and i think she filed a case against him
being abusive towards her
but then i forget what exactly happened
but then obviously like he won the case
well when she was abusing him like you
could hear the recording she was like no
one's going to believe you anyway no
one's going to believe you they'll just
you know people are going to do that did
he win he did okay and like i think
there were like some videos coming up
like where she would just like randomly
raise her hand and he'd like flinch
and it's oh man that's just so sad
it was her and not him but that's not
genuinely at all not him that's
generally believed though yeah do you
know what i mean it's generally believed
that it's going to be him it's going to
be the man that's going to be the abuser
there was a moment where he kind of got
blackballed in like the acting community
or whatever because people actually
believe the others yes exactly well
that's the thing i feel like when a girl
accuses a guy of something
like people just automatically assume
like like what does it believe believe
all women women believe all women but
i'm like some of these girls are crazy
like you can't you can't believe all
girls i've been i've been accused of of
hit of hitting a woman really yeah i've
been accused what happened
um i've been accused of pushing a woman
down two flats of stairs
i had to go to court for it oh my god
i got found not guilty but it's just the
fact that
i was there you were there
there was no injuries like what are you
talking about like we we may have had an
argument yeah right but
what are you talking about but because
women generally know they can call the
police and be believed
they have to investigate and i'm like
but so what was her evidence there
wasn't any
it was it was my it was literally my
word against against herself and so
yeah yeah
yeah i got found not guilty because they
had they undelivered they only
deliberated for like 10 minutes
and they were like
that's just so like disrespectful to
like all women that have been exactly
thankful
it's just like oh it's just so
disappointing
like for women to even have the courage
to stand up because it's very like
frowned upon on different like aspects
and it's so hard yeah it's hard it's so
hard as an individual to stand up and be
like this is what happened to me and
actually stand up again to prosecute
another person for what they did to you
and they don't get found guilty
because of women that do lie and
exaggerate their situation for their own
benefit um and they do you know what i
mean and it just it looks bad on other
women that actually do get go for the
thing it's the reason why i can be
accused like me like okay i'm six foot
two black i'm black and yeah you know
what i mean
it's easy to believe that i am always
going to be the aggressor you know what
i mean and so was it can i ask um what
race your
double black they're all black there's a
black one young black woman yeah as a
black woman and so but but she's a woman
and so she's going to be believable
right she's going to be believed right
and it's like well
if i have like no
history of abusing women and that this
just comes out of the blue for me i know
i'm like what are you talking about but
it doesn't matter that really doesn't
matter when they can't undo the
character assassination like there might
be people that like believe like there
was a case where a dude was um
he was
a girl said that she she was assaulted
by him and it came out that she lied but
like you can't undo everyone on campus
thinking he was a rapist for like oh
great got to say great but like for um
great because you can't say
great
yeah yeah
for two years you know because or
however long the trial is um
yeah that does
has there ever been a case where the guy
sues like the woman for defamation like
defamation i don't know but i know there
was a case in america where
a woman said that um a guy raped her
[Music]
she um but it came to find out that she
dreamt it
was it was okay yeah she dreamt it but
he actually went to prison for it really
he went to prison for grape yeah but how
did they find out she jumped like
because i think afterwards like
afterwards he appealed and
have you heard of it yeah like she she
dreamt it did she actually believe it
happened to her though
i don't know i i don't believe it i bet
she just
if that was the case that that would
have been the procedure do you think
that she was like too far like she
started singing and she realized it was
a dream and she was like too far in it
and she couldn't she like was too
embarrassed to take i don't i don't know
but i think she should go to jail i
think any girl that like does that
should go to jail even if you retract
because you're like oh i'm sorry like it
was my mistake but remember though when
those kind of cases happen we know the
man
you're right don't know the woman like
everything is put out about the man he's
in the press he's in the papers he's on
social media he was accused of this
thing and it's like who's the woman no
one knows but i think nowadays nowadays
they do know who the woman is because
they do tell like both stories but her
her character is not assassinated like
his it's like a man if if a man is
accused of anything like that he's
finished it doesn't matter we did it or
not yes he's finished but would you
couldn't you argue the other way where
they do
like say oh this woman like she does go
out drinking she likes to wear all this
and this she's like barely wears any
clothes or high heels but doesn't mean
you should be like well obviously but i
mean don't you wouldn't you say like
they're like what is it the media is
basically trying to blame the woman yeah
and that's and that's the thing that's
why when i hear
me personally when i hear that men have
been accused of something like this
i just
wait for all the evidence to come out
i'm not saying he did it didn't do it
i'm not saying she's lying she's not
lying i'm just like let me just wait to
see but people generally there was a
case um in the uk last year there was a
woman um
i actually spoke about it there was a
old lady who killed her husband
right she was like penelope jackson was
her name penelope jackson she killed her
husband and when the police came
and because they had their body cameras
and they um they filmed it she was so
not she was like yeah he deserved it he
was an abuser and he done this and blah
blah blah and because she said that yeah
all the women just jumped to her defense
yeah she must have been going through so
much she must she she must have been
pushed to the edge come to find out when
it got to her jury she got 18 years for
killing him because she was lying but
the thing is is that it doesn't really
matter
it's the fact that she said it
and women just believed her yeah
and that's that do you know what i mean
that that's that and yeah you're you're
now guilty into you you're proven
innocent when you when something like
that happens
or even with that like supreme court
justice at the u.s um what was it um
you know i'm talking about the supreme
court justice a couple years back
where that girl like came out
um and said he assaulted her in college
right as he became like he was nominated
for the court yes
his name though and the media the media
like painted him as such a bad guy but
if you watch the full like interrogation
and like the trial and stuff
they found nothing on him and the whole
world
like they see him as a rapist well
the president of the united states
currently
has a allegation against him from a
woman called tara reed and we haven't
even heard about it tara reid
joel biden has been accused by a woman
named tara reid of digitally inserting
his fingers in her while he was in
office
that's the case no one hears about it
that's right
well the case is
you can look at it right now like you
can go on in and
type up tara reid and she has accused
joe biden of sexually assaulting her by
in certain joe biden yeah
wait i'm sorry i thought you said obama
no joe biden
that's okay yeah
wait pause really quick
pause really quick
thank you ninja watcher for life for the
20 super chat it says milk camera money
can't wait to see the new cameras guys
do you do you want like a close-up of
our faces wouldn't it be nice like a
little camera here
camera there send a donation okay
help a girl all the money i don't even
keep any of it
i don't keep any of it i just reinvest
it into the podcast okay
oh no the
this is playing i was looking at the
comments
okay so
next question i have
um
so you have interesting views on
monogamy
i would really
like to hear
i would really like to hear you talk
about what your views on monogamy are
um okay so i spoke about this a few
times and
there is a
social scientist
by the name of robert p barash who wrote
a book called out of eden
and in that book he
basically he basically said that human
beings are not wired to be monogamous
um
he was saying that
this is his his argument that human
beings are more closer to apes
and apes aren't monogamous like a
certain percentage of apes are not
monogamous
and so
when
quote-unquote cheating happens
it's because of a biological and
a wiring let's say that a lot of men
have and he was also saying that
prior to um western colonization of the
world
most people whether you go to
africa asia middle east we're living in
some kind of poliginous or polygamous
type situation and it's only the coming
of the western civilization where
everyone said okay one man for one woman
whereas generally before that people
were living in
you know
multiple type relationship scenarios so
it's like yeah when when he put it like
that i was like oh okay cool because
a lot of women now they wonder why you
know men are cheating men are cheats man
of dogs blah blah and it's like
well
maybe they're not wired that way and i'm
not saying that because i've been in
monogamous relationships
i'm not saying that men cannot be
monogamous
i'm saying that
probably a lot of them are not
but what is happening is that because
i believe women have been sold the dream
of monogamy house kids
white picket fence my husband mike
they've been like that dream of like
prince charming has been sold
in this society
a lot of
people don't understand why
a lot of men are doing like doing this
kind of stuff and i'm not making excuses
for men doing it i'm just saying a lot i
think the conversation needs to be had
because i think
um
a lot of men are lying to themselves and
also lying to their women because i'm
telling you as a man men know whether
they're monogamous or not right they
know when they get into a relationship
whether they're going to cheat on this
woman or not oh
you know what i mean so
if they know
can a woman handle being told you know
what i do
because don't get me wrong men love
their woman they can say you know what
baby i love you i want to be for the
rest of my life
but
if the rest of my life is the next 50
years
do you think your vagina is the only
vagina i'm going to see for that next 50
years
how realistic is that that's what i'm
asking like how realistic is that do you
know what i mean like
a question of course so if you're saying
that so then
what if the man were to be like you know
able to be in like an open relationship
would it be i mean you'd have to say
like oh the woman can also do the same
as well can't you um i think so this is
my personal opinion now this is not like
anything but i think when it comes to
women and
that
the
the
murky water on that is
if she was to get pregnant who's whose
baby would it be yeah do you know what i
mean like who's whose child would it be
would it be the guy's child would it be
that guy's child would you would it
would a man just say okay cool it
doesn't matter it's from him
and it's going to be all of our child
men ain't really built that way i think
there's a reason why you know lions when
they take over a pride they kill all the
children
of
the previous women
it's like because it's like no i want to
start my thing like i don't care about
those like they literally kill the
babies of that thing they're like i want
to start my thing and it's like men
generally are wired differently for
women i think
i just think it's different i don't know
i think it's just hard to compare animal
like mammals because like i would say
like humans were like a little more
intelligent you know yeah like
emotionally
and just like common like i don't know
how to say the word like common sense we
have a little bit more they're more
conscious they're more conscious of
animals yeah yeah
so
i wouldn't be like oh you know because
like a
what is a family of wine kills like
another person's child then that means
like oh like no but how many of you have
been cheating
how many have you been cheating on
you've been cheated on right
so there's so many women out there
[Music]
there's so many women that i've been
cheated on right yes why
well because we like a small percentage
like if um it's like if you ask 80 of
women what they want in a man they list
20 of men sometimes even less right so
like for example only 15 ish percent of
guys are over six foot like i don't know
the exact number so if you want a guy
over six five six two i'm
good all right
and let's say you add like you know
money on top of that it's like a smaller
and smaller percentage of guys and then
you know chemistry vibes whatever it is
yeah whatever and then you realize that
you're like competing for like a very
small yeah and that small group of men
understand that they're being competed
for right and so their options are
boundless and it's like if you're going
for those kind of guys who have
boundless options it's like
do you think they're not gonna try and
take one of those options at one point
in time like do you really think so
and i'm not saying that it's right or
wrong by the way i'm not i'm just saying
it happens i have a follow-up question
do you do you believe women are
hypergamous of course they are okay
so
hypergamy is just means like
i would say the best way to describe it
is we want to get the best possible like
maybe we can get yeah we want to date up
so then by that like logic do you think
if we if i have a family and i can do
better
within my husband i should leave my
husband because by nature i'm
hypergamous i don't think you should um
sorry excuse me i don't think you should
leave your husband who you've made a
commitment to
just because you're hypergamers so
so then would you say the same thing for
men you shouldn't cheat on your wife
that you've made the commitment to just
because yeah yeah i would i would i
actually would i think if you make a
commitment okay
you are bound by that commitment okay
i believe that however i i think a lot
of people make commitments not being
honest
yeah and that's why yeah that's true
that is why
the cheating happens
if a guy came to him like you know what
baby i love you we've been together for
this long
but you know at some point in time i'm
just i'm just gonna do something right
that's more honest but you as a woman
have to now decide whether you're okay
with that and that's being honest what
men do is like no baby you're gonna be
arrested the rest of my life is with you
and no one else it's like stop lying
so i think yeah if you make a commitment
and you sign a contract you should be
upheld to that contract i think i think
many people sign that contract
and i think that's it's so important to
like know who you are i think a lot of
men think oh women need to find
themselves i think that's like more like
stereotype like women need to understand
themselves know themselves but men need
to know who they are yes in order to
make such a commitment like know what
you're know who you are as a person
before you make a comment like i can
commit to you
but you can't because as a like no but
he can
no if he wants to he will but like so to
a certain extent it's not in their
character like no but
women think that a man committing or not
committing is having such a cover man
they are like you can still be like a
man that's okay with monogamous
relationship but maybe or not maybe you
prefer polyamorous relationships and
maybe you just don't understand that but
you're committing to that knowing you're
still going to be right in your face
right but if you actually understood
yourself studied yourself you actually
put in the time and levels of commitment
to being like you know what this is who
i am and then knowing what you can give
to a woman that's a different thing
but to know to not actually fully put in
that work and then be like you know what
baby i can commit to like i know you
can't like i have a follow-up question
would you guys
be open to an open relationship where
the guy can step out from time to time
but it's just it's just sex there's no
no no no no no no no but listen listen
listen wait wait wait but you know i'm
gonna go to the bathroom and come back
okay i'm back okay but but all of your
bills are taking care of the rest of
your life you don't have to work you can
get like whatever you want you can have
as many kids as you want like you
the rest of your life you're good you
just have to deal with him stepping out
from time to time
you put up a
heartbeat right in there pearl no go
ahead
um you know i would love
love to say that i would but knowing
myself and the green monster that is in
me
i am a jealous [ __ ]
so
you know like if i i mean
you might you might kill the girl i
might no i might kill the man
i would just be like you know like
i don't know like like why
could you do it and why could i not
because you don't have to pay like
that's the trade-off is as he's saying
you get all my resources you don't have
to work so i get to cheat that's that's
the i might as well just have a sugar
daddy at that point what that's like
well you're the only one that gets his
emotional commitment so all the other
girls they're just like
just physical he doesn't really because
men you know they can sleep with a girl
and not care about her yeah yeah i'm
sorry for me it's gonna be an absolutely
not looking right at the camera so you'd
rather you'd rather so you'd rather work
the rest of your life and just have a
guy that's loyal i mean i would i do not
want to
i would actually love to be working the
rest of my life like i don't i feel like
if i weren't then i'd just be like
you know i mean like nothing against
housewives but i would just be bored
yeah you know
to answer that question
that men can have sex
with a woman
that's what pearl just said and not
having connections
yeah
i mean women can do it too but a thing
is just like but it's easier for men
though
because we
we can detach ourselves from the act
because it's to a lot of men it's just
an act
why why is that
because
that's just how we're wired like we're
just wired different like we can have
sex with the like
[Music]
i know guys
that have had sex with a woman
and forgot that they even had sex with
her
do you know what i mean like is that
because it wasn't it was just because
it was it was just that it was just the
act and so
they meet her and they're like
do i know you from
and she's like yeah you do and he's like
oh sh oh oh did we oh oh [ __ ] okay
because it's just an act but you know i
would say just like from personal
experiences that i've been able to
separate
physical and emotional as well right i
feel like just as easily as like any man
can
were you
were you able to do that like right away
or did you kind of have to learn that
like i'm
like i was able to do it like first
first like
five-ish guys you slept with yeah like
you could detach yeah it was just like
you know like a night out okay you know
you just want to let go whatever you
just do it
yeah
i mean i feel like it's just like all
power to me you know i yeah
get
what i want without
what is it the luggage right yeah we've
got the baggage yes right
i can't
you know look at me
right without the like you know oh like
what are you trying to do with this like
just like just done what i'm done
no i get that but i just think that
generally
men have an
easier time
doing that like even in a relationship
because sometimes a lot of the time
there have been women there have been
married men men that have been in like
committed relationships and they've
quote unquote cheated with someone and
people like you you cheated with her
that's what we talked about last time
when you realize
when you realize you have to be worried
about the ugly girls too
like why
but the reason why it's her because
yeah it's like it wasn't because it was
just an act like they just it wasn't
because i was emotionally involved with
this woman or you know like
i just wanted to release yes yes you
wanted to [ __ ] and that's that was it
and so
yeah a lot of women
don't get that about men but i'm trying
to let them understand like men can just
have sex and just be out but my thing is
like i wouldn't ever want to do that
because like
what are the odds if you catch him doing
it once what are the odds that he's
going to stop and like how do you if
he's lying to you about that how can you
trust him about anything well that's
what i'm trying to talk about yeah lying
thing yeah
that's why i talk about lying thing it's
not about lying it's not being honest
but most people don't want to have that
honest conversation
so like
i think
it'd be different if they were like say
like there's a man and a woman in a race
trip and like
they're an open relationship
i think it'd be fine if they were both
to like tell them like tell both of each
other like oh yeah i hooked up with this
person oh yeah like just not hiding
anything not hiding any of the details
because i have i do have like a friend
that are like they're married
or friends that are married and they do
have that relationship and it works very
well for them
but so
i forget what like what my what point i
was going to make but i would say like
you know like i feel like that's so both
of them like the men and the women cheat
oh they go elsewhere so i would say so
they like
they go out together i've actually been
out together with them
like while they're like
on the prowl
not on the prowl but i mean just like
you know they're going they're both
looking for like
real that's like a hook-ups thing or
something not really i mean it's just
like they're going out and they're like
okay like i might find someone and they
both like tell each other like is this
okay is that okay
and then they just like you know they
there's a lot of communication i think
that's key to making that work
100 yeah and honestly yeah have you ever
seen 100 sorry no i was just going to
say would that be because you said
cheating would that be considered
cheating if they are both in an
agreement no no no
i would say is if
there's lying involved and then hooking
up behind the back yes not mine involved
if there's not lying involved and you
know
what like what do you mean
okay
so say that
i'm in a relationship and my dude's like
hey yo i'm going to hang out at
my
friend's house and he tells me who the
friend is the girl
but it doesn't give me
or
yeah it doesn't give me like full
details of what's going to happen is
that would you consider that line
like doesn't get if
like doesn't give you the full details
and then ends up hooking up with her i
would say that's cheating
yeah i would i wouldn't say that
cheating
but
like lying about going to her like not
saying that maybe his ex would be at a
party or something or like something
like that yeah do you oh do you think
that dancing on another guy as a girl
is cheating so like grinding really no
it depends on like your partner's
culture as well like for example i'm
going to use carnival
for like um what they like doing their
culture like i feel like if you're going
with the guy say you're not of the same
culture i'm not talking about cultural
dances i'm talking about like grinding
like anna got like a girl girl goes back
that's what she's talking about oh is it
the same thing okay okay okay okay okay
yeah that's integrated have you ever
examined you're in the uk now you're
gonna go to carnival yeah so for example
say um
my partner's from the caribbean
carnivals have come in august i feel
like i know you're gonna do like i mean
i'm jamaican i actually i'm i don't know
part of your culture it's for me to
understand that though as well me as a
person even if i'm part of the culture
i'm gonna know that like you're gonna
know i'm gonna go do my thing as well
but it's not
for them in your culture like for them i
don't speak on it maybe you can speak on
that but um it's not like for them in
their eyes it's not cheating she knows
it's not cheating yeah it's more like
that's what they call that's what they
do okay but let's not i'm not trying to
do it under the guise of like culture
i'm talking like some girls go to a bar
that one has a boyfriend and she's
grinding and like twerking on another
guy
it's problematic like yeah i would say
yeah
i would say that
it's
it goes down to what do they agree to in
the relationship because
a guy may not
may not care like oh yo yeah you can go
dance on whoever over there i don't care
about it because you come home with me
tonight but a girl may have some may
have a problem
if
he if she sees her man
and another woman is dancing with him
she may be like uh on that well i feel
like a lot of couples don't have that
conversation and i think yeah and have
conversations
and i think that a lot of guys don't
like i don't know i'll see girls like
with boyfriends like grinding on these
other guys i'm like
would your boyfriend be cool with that
because i i don't know
i'm like if i'm in a relationship and i
go out and i'm with my man i'mma dance
with my man about it no no i'm talking
about without
i'm not going to dance on anybody really
yeah
the key thing is she doesn't know
carnival she doesn't know the uk the
carnival she doesn't know
i think the key thing is like basically
the communication relationship like you
need to talk about it from the start
like oh like do you consider this like
cheating or like if i were to do this
like would it hurt your feelings you
know you just have to clarify everything
so that you know like maybe not like
from the start maybe like before you go
out with your girls you'll be like okay
like let's talk about this
just so like if you were to do something
then you know it wouldn't hurt their
feelings and then obviously if you knew
it would then you wouldn't do it
but say like if you don't know and you
do it because you don't consider that
cheating then i think that's a
completely different story i really do
think relationships are evolving yeah
nowadays i think relationships are not
like our grandparents generation they're
just evolving and i think what what we
can see now is
you know that um
you know that when something's changing
you have that
crazy time when
things are changing and it's like
a bit crazy i think it's hard to talk
about it's how to talk about it's hard
to do people don't know what's going i
think we're in that time and i think i
don't know give it another 50 years and
the types of relationships that will be
um what we think are crazy nowadays will
just be normal you know what i mean so i
think we're in that transition stage
yeah
that's true i have been you know i've
seen a lot of what is it like social
media couples where it's like two girls
one man yeah i see that they're
revolving
but are they evolving or are they going
back to what they were that's the thing
what are you oh
that is interesting are they going back
are we reverting back to who we are did
we did this point in time in history
just tried to show us that as something
different and it's like uh you guys
can't do that go back to what you were
doing like is is that what is going on
here that's that's what i don't know now
we're more open to different things yeah
the world is evolving for example back
in the day like certain things a lot of
things were like more frowned upon like
there were more rules in in like in
place i think you see i don't think that
but it's mostly like people's culture as
well like back in the day it was
more harder and more harder to be open
to who you are whereas now it's more
open and you can't be who you are
but it's literally all down to that
communication i don't
i don't like the way it's involved but i
think i cuz i just grew up in such like
a old school traditionally no my because
my my parents traditionally you know my
nationals my parents have like they've
only slept with each other and i think
there's yeah in their life yeah and i
think and i think
no no no
no no they started
that's what that's what everyone says
actually on the internet but i swear i
would bet like my my life i would bet
don't do that i would no i would
not no no no no no
no
no don't vouch for anyone you don't know
no but you know what i'm not sorry to
cut you though um um
what i've noticed in in my life is
people hide things very well
100
and they know how to appear
a one-way
and something's going on and i'm not
saying that your parents aren't like
that you know i don't want to i'm not
trying to spread parents at all i'm not
trying to do that but i'm just saying
we don't know
but obviously you're gonna but that's
like how you're gonna view the world
like through your life experiences right
so you know fair enough but i'm saying
like like i have nine siblings
oh they'd be busy
and i just i think i think there's a
level like because they both like
maintained a level of purity like before
they like met each other i feel like
yes yeah that's what i'm saying
my mom
my mom met him when she was 17. that's
what i'm saying like and they built a
multi-million dollar business they had
10 kids and like we live in it like i
feel like they want to adopt me
like you're like
i would say you're one of the lucky ones
like yeah but i think like more that's
not
necessarily the norm that's not yet
you're you're not the norm you're like
but i feel like i feel like their
marriage is better because they don't
have all these like like connect like
you know you date someone for two years
and you marry someone else right you
still have that like connection with the
last person and like how many exes come
back and like ruin marriage yeah and all
that like i feel like their marriage was
better yes because they only have each
other i get that and like i feel like it
worked better that way like when women
got married younger and like we don't
have to date for 10 years and get our
hearts broken like isn't it that's
amazing you know
that you're that yeah amazing your
family is cool yeah yeah
well and like my mom actually got
pregnant when she was 17 like by my dad
and they gave that kid up for adoption
and then like we reunited with him later
but like
i don't know they're just like he's paul
in the family now yeah sort of like not
i mean he can't come to everything
because he has his own stuff but yeah
like he comes to stuff
yeah it's weird he's so similar to us
like even though we look like you guys
oh yeah yeah
i could show you it's a whole family of
redheads guys yeah
do you know what's so funny we don't put
them red
but even like because even if you do the
one-sided like open relationship like
guys still can get feelings for their
side check like that that's still
opening your marriage up like i mean
guys leave their wives for their side
chick that's like
yeah but any side chick that thing said
that their man's gonna lead the wife
it's not it's not the norm but you're
opening your marriage up to like a
possible like why risk
yeah yeah complete breakage like so i
just yeah i just prefer the traditional
i think it works better than
no i hate you yeah and i think the way
in which your parents done everything is
commendable if if i'm to i i commend
that i'm not yeah that's the one that we
gave up for adoption
so like that's everyone
that's when we gave up for adoption he's
definitely part of your family
i have a funny story um yeah
that i saw it was anything was on
youtube or snapchat or something
and
you were it sparked my memory when
you're talking about how
men can't be uh monogamous i'm not
saying they can't be it's it's just
harder for them yeah yeah so there's
this uh
polyamorous group and it's one
one woman and she has uh three
men yep i don't i can't remember
i can't remember if they were married
but she
she that's a sausage party she has um
they were like all talking about it
they were all like they interviewed each
one and they're like yeah like
they interviewed the first guy like yeah
we met such a time and then we started
talking about blah blah and they brought
another dude like yeah we met here and i
was like sure i'm down for it guys the
third one don't do that and so she gets
pregnant by one of the dudes and the
interviewers like so who's going to be
the father and he was like one of the
guys were like well i guess we're all
going to be the father and it was just
weird like to see their faces
and their dynamics it was like they
really
they really don't don't want that they
really don't want to like be there it's
just like they were all just there
for her but they really didn't want the
other dudes okay so yeah i don't
generally use the term
like beta and alpha and stuff like that
i don't generally do that
okay like if you're if if you're a man
and your woman is having sausages from
other places right
and you're there while she's having the
sausages like i don't understand
that is a de-emasculation process i
would say as a man like i couldn't just
i wouldn't want my woman just having so
what about the other way around
because
so in my in my career right so
i have worked for very um high net worth
individuals like i was saying right
mm-hmm and let me tell you i've worked
for very rich men
the wives of these men
they know these men are cheating they
know these men got side chicks but you
know what
they're cool because they've got the
house they've got the kids they've got
everything that's paid for they got
everything that's done but they know
they know he goes out there and does his
thing but they're cool
men that do that i'm like
that's more of a women are used to that
kind of behavior that's why you were
saying genghis khan had how many what
he had um multiple women
hella i i i worked for
i actually worked for um a guy who was a
king in africa
and he had eight wives
and all the wives they just they just
they knew
i think men say
personally i think women are made for
more polyamorous relationships than men
and then why do we have to go on birth
control to do it
if we're made for it but i think what do
you mean
like to have a polyamorous relationship
like you have to go on birth control
wait that's that's why there's condoms
as well i know what i'm saying like if
it's natural to us so then why don't men
just have birth control because men
naturally want to spread their seed so
like thank you bro yeah
thank you that's what i'm saying it's
literally it's literally not natural to
us because like
the reason we want it like everyone
wants to have sex is because like
there's biological reasoning like we
want to reproduce so women we want to
reproduce with the highest like value
guy we can
where
where
men just want kids left and right like
biologically but like you know
guys don't don't be having like five
baby mamas that's trash no don't do that
don't do that don't do that
um
that's where that's that's one area
where i see the like relationships are
going and there are there are men who
have
baby mama here baby mommy here baby
mommy here baby i'm here and you see it
a lot in people who do have money
because they're just like i'm just gonna
have this baby mama have that baby mama
had that baby mama and it's like
well it's hard to see that and
what's his name what's the guy's name um
the guy who done um
while he now
oh
yeah doesn't he have like nineteen
minutes
guys
guys guys even when i ask
multiple women and they're all cool with
it well even when i asked you guys
earlier if if you'd accept it from a guy
if he made more money like you oh you
might not have said yes but you thought
about it
it's almost like they earned the right
to change
a lot of women that do like their
relationship for example like you know
like um
muslim culture like you know men can
have like different wives they can have
four wives
and that's yeah that's about the men
taking care of them yeah but
realistically like let's say as a person
who they are that's not going to change
because of their culture like who they
are is different so for example like
they could be like yeah you could have
three more wives but that's because
their cultures chose them on that path
yeah but that doesn't mean that they're
like okay like do you know what go have
two more wives like they're not okay
with that though you think as a woman
though you can be in love with more than
one man
no i think there's love on different
levels okay yeah but i feel like you can
maybe you can be in love with different
people for different things
yeah like i feel like you don't believe
all right i feel like you can you can be
in love with just one person you can
love multiple people right but you can
only be in love with one person
you know there's a difference with like
loving
people and like being actually in love
with someone and being like wanting to
sacrifice everything you have like for
them like you you don't want to do that
for multiple people i feel like there's
just one person that you'd want to do
that for
you so you can you can be in love with
more than one man i disagree only
because i can see it from like a
friendship level was all like i have
this friend here like she's literally
like my sister i'll do anything for her
and i have like different friends
but i feel like that kind of that kind
of problem you're talking about in love
i'm talking about friends
i'm actually like so in like i'm not
explaining it so you're in love with her
will you will you hook up with her
but what defines love like love is love
love is love but i mean like like is it
because i'm sexually intimate with that
person yeah
is that is that not like a different
sector of that are you sexually intimate
with her no
so are you in love with her but love is
love now
nah there's different types
i love my siblings as humans we
complicate love so so you think that the
love you have for your parents is the
same type of love that you have for the
guy you're sleeping with yeah like come
on why are we
different there's different levels of
love you can only be in love with one
person in one time
that's what i'm saying i'm saying as a i
know
and i'm a man myself
well i can be in love
with more than one woman in love in love
[Music]
like and that's the thing about love
though because it's
it's a personal thing isn't it do you
know what i mean like so
i'm not because it wasn't no but i'm
saying love is a personal thing but i
know i can be in love with more than one
woman but even if you were i've actually
been there wouldn't you at one point
what do you value i feel like it's just
natural for us to value one more than
the other
as a woman no
as a human you didn't have a favorite as
a human being
for different reasons because if that
makes sense yeah but you didn't have one
like
no no for different like if i if i have
like if i'm in love with like two women
i'm not by the way this just get out
there right
like so if
you love them
you're in love with them for different
reasons and they
they tick different boxes than the other
one but you love
different things about them that you may
not get in the other person you're going
with my point about friendships as well
though because we all have different
friends with different that's not like
sexual love is different from your
parents sometimes
like love is love can i just wait let me
finish my question love is love and i
feel like each person that's what i
understand i so understand polyamorous
relationships right like i feel like
different people do different things for
you so why you love for them it's what
they can do for you right and what they
bring out of you
right yeah that's why i completely
understand it so what you really did say
is kind of contradicting it no i mean
but you're telling me like no it's not
different it's not no but love
friendships being different things for
you as to why you have different love
for different people yeah but the thing
is with your partner
or partners you're going to have a
sexual side of the relationship of
course so
that's not the same kind of love as you
have for your sibling or your mother or
your father or your friend yeah or your
friend
what are you arguing like i just feel
like you're arguing nothing like you're
like
he's saying he has a sexual love for two
different girls
yeah yeah it's a sexual love yeah
because sex is involved within
differentiates
what is it well i don't have sex with my
siblings or my mom or my dad right
you've been loving like two different
girls so you wasn't like two different
girls yes what difference is that
because you're getting sex from both
those girls yes what differentiates that
makes you think but what what makes this
girl more or is it like you don't even
there's no there's no more or less okay
i was in love with both of those women
at that time
was that me like i was in love with both
of those women yeah yeah was that like a
like an open relationship or something
no no it really wasn't actually it was a
situationship type situation but it was
in my like 20s and stuff
yeah it was like an entanglement
no but it was like when i was in my 20s
i actually felt like i was in love with
two different women that's what i'm
saying polyamorous relationships yeah i
feel like
literally different people do different
things for you and brings out a
different side to you and what like who
you are as a person so i do understand
like
why people do end up polyamorous
relationships so you think women can do
the same thing be in love with two men
at this three men four men at the same
time
completely like yeah i wouldn't even put
sexual assault i wouldn't quantify that
personally because i can't speak from
experience
um but i feel like it is possible
looking at
experience i've heard from other people
people can't like even women i'll say
women's experience i've heard from um
you can be in love with two people
i feel like it's like men
it's about what they bring for you and
what they bring out of you
it just depends on the person and this
goes back to what i was saying earlier
on about
human beings being in a more polyamorous
or
polygamous relationship prior to
this system that we currently have and i
i really do think
this part i mean it just thinks that
we're
reverting back to
that time
and the thing is this kind of schism
that we're having
this oh men are trash women are trash i
think this is the i think that's the the
i think that's
it's because
no it's because we're all sleeping with
the same guys so women think men are
trash because we're all sleeping with
the same ones okay and then men think
women are trash because these all these
guys can't get laid and the girls they
do get laid from like don't give a [ __ ]
about them because they they don't
actually want them they just like that
i think so i think it's like the bottom
i know i think it's like the bottom like
i i the bottom like 80 of guys or
whatever 50 of guys they're the angry
ones at women typically because the guy
the girls talking about like the in
cells yeah yeah right yeah
or okay i have two things um
one i think that
women can
be in love with two people but i think
is more so
what happens to women is this
relationship they have over here
there's a distance they're still in love
with that person but there's a distance
and then they go to another person that
they're not in a relationship with and
they end up falling in love with them
and there was just
an emotional disconnect with the first
person i think that happens more so
than them being in love with
two people i i agree because i feel like
girls like
like i feel like i've only been in love
twice right but i feel like both of
those guys like i'll always you know
they're the same type of love
you love them the same
uh what do you mean question um
no i mean the relationships were
different right like they're they're
completely different um
but i feel like i still like there's a
party that always like cares about
someone if you've spent enough time with
them for long enough
yeah there's like yeah but that's that's
what i said earlier i feel like
marriages would be better with like lots
of those
right you know
so
so then you can see that
you can love
right but i would have two different
people differently
yeah but actually yeah but i wouldn't
say like i'm still in love with either
does that make sense
i get that but i'm saying you understand
that you can be in love with two
different oh yeah because they were like
yeah they were they the two guys were
very different yeah yeah yeah and they
they probably brought out different
sides of you in that relationship no i'm
pretty weird regardless
[Music]
that's all aspects of relationships that
can be parents
like mother father like whichever um
friends and like your partner like not
genderflying them like it's literally
each other like it depends on what they
bring out of you like what you connect
with i think that's like an emotional
there's just different aspects like
sexual emotional mentally like
spiritually how many times have you been
in love
would you say
zero
you've never been alive wow
like i really felt like
in love like on that level like that i
think i've heard people describe but i
think it's all um altered to each
individual's experience but you've never
experienced it i don't feel like i've
experienced in love no you've been in
love
that's sad
i've been twice twice are you in love
now
you know
i knew
oh my gosh
um anyways i'll just talk about the
first two okay okay
so there's a third
i wouldn't
absolutely i wonder because you know i'm
still getting to know this man so i
don't know yet okay
i like that
you should be a man yes well yes who
wants a boy
um the first one was the one that
cheated on me mm-hmm hurt my heart the
second one
so like we weren't we were never
official anything right but i think we
both knew that you were in love that we
both were and then whether the same was
the same type of love
yeah i would say it was a little more
intense what was more intense the one
that you weren't actually with or i
think it was just more like i was more
grown and i just knew like
you know when you just feel like you
understand emotions a little bit more
and then that's just how it was and i
was like okay this is happening but i
was also like i was going to school in
boston
he was still in san francisco
and there was a lot of things like it's
what and but
and you know every time i came back like
we'd hang out all the time like
basically like every day when i was back
home
and then
when i was gone like it would just be
like you know like every so often we'd
message each other
but there was like one time
like oh
this is i wouldn't say this was cheating
because i can't say it was cheating
because we weren't together
it was like my second biggest heartbreak
because
it was like probably like winter and he
like told me he's like oh i'm with this
girl
but then in the summer
he's like oh i've been in a relationship
with this girl since the summer
and i'm like okay wait no sorry in the
summer he told me in the winter he said
that that's when it started i'm like
okay
so
when we're here on spring break why can
you tell me then yes because i couldn't
tell you because i didn't want to and
i'm like okay but why he goes just cuz
and i'm like
okay
and i literally that was oh that was one
the second time i went crazy again like
out of our drinking i was like throwing
punches i was screaming and crying like
in the alleyway
you were punching him thank you thank
you like in the chest though not the
face
it doesn't make you [ __ ] no no it
doesn't well then it's fine
of course
but but wait you had you really had no
like to stand
you were punching him
i'm not full-on i think i was just like
answer your crazy question yes
hundred percent
so one what i'm trying to say is
internet forever
but what i'm trying to say most people
okay i imagine if a man came on a
podcast and said yeah i was punching
this girl and was going
yeah yeah yeah it's a double standard
it's
crazy
yeah it's a double standard
oh my god they'll be cancelled tomorrow
i'll be cancelled
but sorry continue sorry i'm gonna
cancel me no no
you know you're not gonna get canceled
anyway
you're welcome
so was were you done with him after that
oh man it's
not really oh dang i see both loves kind
of cheated on you then
yeah have you cheated
have you cheated um not on never
actually not or never what was what was
that answer
okay can we get some clarification
please
obviously no woman i've ever spoken to
has ever cheated apparently not anyone
that i've ever taken seriously and i
knew that they were taking me seriously
as well so like if i was like you know
hooking up with you like every so often
like obviously like
yeah but like like with the
you might have been exclusive
relationships
i want to say like you know we're
cheating
but when he's asking like have you ever
cheated on a man or your partner so i
don't have to fight like anything yeah
yeah um has it been for someone you've
been in an active relationship with or
you've had that exclusivity conversation
like that agreement that's when you're
saying cheating like have you ever
cheated on anything no never there was
never an agreement where we were like oh
yeah so you've never never okay you've
never cheated never sorry that's proud
of you ever cheated
yeah of course no woman's ever cheated
it's never been done i feel like
whatever you commit like that's your
commitment you made like
no i'm just nothing
i'm just saying
the thing is when i speak right i speak
to guys and they say yeah there was
something that happened blah blah blah
but for some reason
women have a hard time admitting that
they've cheated
on someone
like if i've committed to you and i'd be
paid that but the thing is men and women
achieve at
similarly the same rate according to
statistics which is similarly this is
true it's true women get away with it
more than men but apparently no woman's
ever cheated
it's like what the hell is going on this
doesn't make sense
because i feel like with that i feel
like you know i'm not going to defend
women but personally like if i've had
that agreement with you of exclusivity
or we've said like we're in a
relationship and we've had that
conversation then it's different like i
haven't like betrayed that
but it's different if we're not like in
an exclusive relationship and i can i'm
actually open i'm actually technically
single
because i can really do my own thing
right so you've never cheated on anybody
no ever no ever you'd have to be
boyfriend my girlfriend to cheat yeah
yeah of course yeah what happened to you
are you gonna have it like vocalized for
you guys to be not like just some kind
of agreement that you guys are have you
ever witnessed one of your girlfriends
cheating yes yes okay yeah
so those those are the ones that cheat
just not you right okay
eileen can vouch for me you were when i
was in a relationship i was doing
distance which would have been the
easiest to cheat did i did you ever see
me cheat talk to another guy
thank you thank you
and i was in a different country and i
was still loyal
can he say the same
so anyone here that wants to get up
pearly pearl you know where to hit her
up
send me an email
i just think i think the whole cheating
thing is interesting i think men have
been
the the kind of dialogue is that men
cheat oh no women shoot too yeah women's
shoes i think nowadays like as they get
cool men get caught i think they're
stupid with it let me be real i feel
like that's why i said women is more
made for like polyamorous relationships
yeah than men i think so women are
better at cheating themselves
i don't think i don't think men
are
though
stupid with it i think women just look
for it
women look yeah like i don't think it's
natural for a guy to go through a girl's
phone but i feel like we always be in
their phones
hold on because you know what it is i
feel like that's where the whole woman
gets stereotyped as emotional beings we
are emotional but men are very emotional
i think they have a different way of
portraying that but there are men in the
world okay maybe i'm looking for an
exception but they're
do you feel like you're more emotional
than men generally
to an extent but no so
that's interesting i think i'm very good
at controlling my mind so the
relationship that you felt like that you
were the guy
did you respect that man yeah
even though you felt like you were like
basically the guy in here yeah yeah
because it's like this like if i'm still
with you there was no reason for me to
think like no like i'm not going to
respond
sorry i don't think oh sorry thank god
god no i would say i don't think you can
say that
women are more emotional than women i
mean the men sorry i would say that we
have like we i think we said earlier
that we both
process and show it differently
and so i'd say our emotional
intelligence are basically the same it's
just the way that we show it in the way
that we express or react to it is very
very different
because things that hurt us will hurt us
but the way that you react to it is a
hundred percent different than
so
so but you don't think like we have
different hormones than men do so like
emotionally like we're a different
person every single day because because
like it depends where we are in our
cycle you already know you already know
a couple days before our period comes
don't mess with me
would your ex-boyfriend say the same
they would they would they would attach
hang on let me just try and clarify this
are you saying that as a woman
you are acknowledging
that
when you're coming your period you are
differently emotionally the days before
yeah oh my gosh hormonally yeah you
literally are
yeah i'll cry and i'm like why am i
crying all right all right so
if a man was to say
right so you've already acknowledged it
right so if so if a man wants to say
you know what you're coming your period
you're probably a little bit emotional
how would you respond to that well first
of all
when you say that obviously that would
piss the woman off yeah but hang on hang
on but hang on it doesn't make any sense
because you've already acknowledged it
well yes you already know you've
acknowledged the fact that you are
different when you're coming in your
period
but hang on when a man acknowledges it
and says to you uh you know what you're
coming period a little bit why is it why
is it going to piss you off because he's
telling the truth i think because you're
asking this question you already kind of
know the answer i mean
come on
i'm just saying why get pissed off when
you already know my friend used to do
that to me
i agree with what he's saying so i feel
like it's all sort of how a man says it
like in what context that conversation
is in but it's true like if he's saying
like he acknowledges it say you were
also ignored as a woman like i go
through these like premenstrual uh mood
swings or post mental or even during
your menstrual cycle
like why is it crazy if the man says it
to you as a as ammo not even ammo not
ammo it's just an another
like as i think because
it kind of diminished it feels is it
patronizing it makes them feel like
you're diminishing what they feel when
you say so it's feet it's a feelings
thing yes right so that's what and
that's the thing you like men don't men
process information differently from
women right and so a man will be very
logical with his with his uh conclusion
he'll be like oh you know what this
woman is acting this way because okay
maybe she's coming the period right okay
cool this woman's acting this way
because she's common appeared and i'm
just going to say it listen babe you're
acting you're not acting right because
you're coming a period but hang on
you you as a woman yeah
are saying
that's gonna piss me off
but it's in the truth
we can't handle the jesus
and this has happened to you how many
times
wait wait wait multiple times multiple
times now right and so if it's happened
to you once then why wouldn't it get
through your thick [ __ ] skull that
would happen the next time no because
what i'm trying to do is i'm trying to
make you understand that you're being
irrational right now irrational yeah
you're being irrational because i'm
telling you the truth
and you can't handle it
right if i tell you the sky is blue and
you go crazy because the sky's blue now
i'm gonna be like what the hell is wrong
with you like just calm the [ __ ] down
right what
it doesn't make sense it's like i'm
telling you this guy's blue it's it's a
tree it's a fact like why are you so
crazy about a fact i don't i don't get
it i don't get it so you're saying that
um
because i have brothers group around
boys so i i understand right not fully
how they process because they're not
amazing
but
so if someone comes to you saying
something correct and you get hurt like
if i say hey like you have a hair
sticking up like you need to like do
something with that and you were like
well why she coming to me saying that
is that something that the man needs to
check or you need to check how you
accept how they're saying
and i'm not saying i'm not saying just
you i'm just saying just i'm here for
this conversation in general is that
something whenever someone comes to you
and they're
there
and they're just
you know and
people say something to you and they
don't mean it that way but you take it
that way is that something you need to
analyze yourself okay why why did i take
that that way or yeah do i talk to them
and be like hey
did you say it this way okay
accountability is a thing
right maybe it's the tone
no but the thing is but and that's the
thing that sometimes men
like a man will generally men will
generally speak straightforward does
that mean we're not i would say so yeah
we're not talking about that we're not
wondering about it
we're not worried about what type of
time of the month it is for you
we'll just say hey listen this is a cup
but i would say what do you mean it's a
cup
chill to [ __ ] it out
it's a [ __ ] cup okay
but i feel like women take things so
differently like you know like even as a
female i could go up to another female
like say i'm not really defensive i'm
like you know what your hair's sticking
up here well i think ego is such a big
thing for a female yeah oh yeah i think
people always put ego on men no honey
it's females as well and i feel like
they're like what do you mean like
they're just straight on smoke and it's
not i think why are you on snapchat i'm
actually trying to help you i've said
women don't like women generally yeah i
agree like exactly women and it depends
on the country like other women because
because women are women's competition
and so
if you if i said if you were to bring
another three women in here yeah right
the women will be like analyzing these
women like you know [ __ ]
like you know what i'm saying
right so women generally don't like
women did that happen when i came late
when men men's competition for another
man is different from a woman's
community
because a man will a man will look at a
man's
success
when we look at men as a man we look at
them define success all right so you
look at jay-z or puff daddy or warren
buffett or let's bring it out
a man a man will look at another man's
success and maybe be envious of his
success yeah we don't generally i'm not
saying it doesn't happen we don't
generally look at other men and be like
look at his look he's look at what he's
wearing i don't think he's
i'm not saying men don't do it but men
don't look at other men and think oh my
god look at his hair what what okay look
at his boots
women do that women look at other
women's shoes and get jealous of that
[ __ ] and start doing i can i can eat i
don't care
like you said generally yeah generally
there there are some that don't but
i've i've experienced some men that do
and but it's not the
vast majority but i do agree with you
that
i feel like women
not all women but some women are more
materialistic so what we see is what
we're going to analyze we're not going
to think about anything else because we
don't see that we don't know what's
going on we don't care about that but
men are like okay like
i don't they just don't think about
looks it just like doesn't cross their
mind to be like that man looks better
than me another nice looks man they just
they just
act the way they act i would say that a
man can correct me for wrong they would
be
more intimidated or not even intimidated
but analyze a person's personality and
how they carry themselves
more than
women would all right so this is the
thing if a man
if a man walks in a room right
and
women flock towards that man like they
go
like the other men are thinking oh
who the [ __ ] is he like
what's going on with him like does he is
he someone that i don't know
and
we might look at that and wonder to
ourselves why is he getting the female
attention that we're not getting right
but we don't look at
generally
his looks
we're one we're wondering
what is it about this man
that has all the women going towards him
and normally it's success yeah
you know what i mean like normally it's
success
i find that men more like
how they dress i feel like it's what
funny
yeah like the character is so
uncharacteristic so how you portray
yourself do you know what it's image let
me let me actually get down to it it's
actually image like how you portray
yourself like because when you say when
it comes to social status
i don't know you yet so it's like i
could be attracted to you
and it's like
i don't know you okay i'm sorry that's
not a conversation
okay i'm talking i'm asking a question
say you walk into the room i could be so
attracted to you but it's like that's
not based on the person i don't know who
the hell you are
like but that's just me looking at you
how you dress me personally how you
dress how you look how you like maybe
carried yourself into the room that like
you're over your energy but it's not me
like saying oh that's your personality
that's just looking at you but that's
like but even men they look at that and
they're like oh like that's how we dress
they look like materialistic stuff as
well not like women though
look at this is the thing
like you you you no but you're you you
you you're arguing something that's just
like you keep arguing for the exception
you do this all the time it's not the
rule like like
80 80 of like consumer debt is women 80
of consumer buying decisions is by women
right women buy most [ __ ] everything is
marketed towards women yeah yeah so
that's like these are like
whatever it is
yeah
i'm saying like why argue exceptions
when we're talking about the rule you
know what i mean
but correct possibly a woman will look
at a woman's arms what are you gonna say
and be like why is that
why did she get her arms like that
like it's like wonderful
okay i need to say i need to read the
super chat so
so we have a couple coming in starting
with
oh my god i can't read that federico
de la casa i'm sorry if i butchered that
shout out to the great sarah garvey from
italy yes as men we want to spread seed
as a primal instinct that's why all the
men
all around the world men had to learn to
take control of their sexual instinct
the next one
from sandra solomo
meme whatever um
like respectfully respectfully
um if you have a key that opens if you
have a key that opens
all the locks then what is the point of
the lock treat others how you want to be
treated kindergarten lessons
another super chat from sandra solem
women i think are better at cheating
than men are it's still messed up if
it's women are more detail oriented men
tend to focus not on details another one
from sandra it's because women it's
sometimes because sometimes women might
rightfully be upset about something and
men just blame it on their period that's
actually good
be like
he'll be he'll be like he'll he'll be
like we'll be like you cheated on me and
he's like you're just on your beard
no but
like
are you telling me as a man right
there's no argument we can have to say
that you're in your period just calm the
[ __ ] down
that we've been with you for a prolonged
period of time and we can see your your
behavior changing at a certain point in
time
right they know your cycle
are you telling me that that's never an
argument for us no look at me yes you
already know
first of all you already know crazy as
hell
i'm crazy
that pisses the girl off mm-hmm
why would you want to do that again
because he's not trying to piss you off
okay but then if you already know by
saying that it pisses her off yeah but
why would you like but why do you write
for why do you let
what she's trying to like you know it
just makes her feel like what but i'm
saying if you have a conversation and
he's saying like no i legitimately like
this is i think it's because you're on
your period i'm not trying to offend you
right and you have that information
getting upset is a choice
it's a choice
i think that was different
listen i didn't listen to listen you
failed as a listen when i s if men say
forget me if men say that
they're wondering
so are now your feelings
logical right
supposed to trump
his feelings
because
right but what it is is that if he's at
the receiving end
of your feelings
women can do all kinds of stuff right if
i'm at the receiving end of your
feelings
and i'm like
hang on a minute she's only doing this
because
she's and i'm thinking this yeah
i'm gonna say but if you are being more
emotional and using the man as a
quote-unquote punching bag for your
feelings he's going to say something
but you can't say
why would you say that because it's like
they're saying it because you're on the
receiving end of the feelings that's why
that's all
okay
[Music]
we'll just go under the next question
yeah next question next question um
do
let's see
because we've gone over a lot of these
no no i'm just reading because some of
these we i like i didn't ask we've kind
of gone over yeah um
oh do you feel like
okay
if if a guy if a girl is withholding sex
from a man like she hasn't had sex with
him in a year
two years
yeah
you've never had one month is a long
time
i wouldn't wait hold on a week in a long
time are you warm
bags
if you're in a relationship okay okay
yeah if you're in relationship okay
but i'm saying i'm saying do
do we okay okay sorry guys
do men have a right to cheat if the
woman's withholding sex because that
happens there are sexless marriages
where like they haven't had sex in
months
i'm gonna go to the bathroom and come
back in the context of marriage or yeah
marriage america i wouldn't say there's
a right but i think like you know that
man definitely needs to talk with that
woman because god damn
[Music]
in a marriage
i personally think there has to be like
something wrong where like that's not
happening because in a marriage i'm not
saying like yeah every day you got to do
it but
essentially like we talked about in the
last podcast um
that physically
men like that's something that men like
yeah is just in them and it's like
why what's the reason that you're
withholding it from them yeah
that's i don't think is acceptable like
i don't think it's okay to cheat but i
understand if you haven't like slept
with him in like a year six months like
what is he supposed to guys no side
conversations
like what is he supposed to do you know
what i mean yeah i
it's a tough situation
um his hand is there
if uh
and what about vice versa do you think
it's okay for a woman to cheat if he
won't have sex with her no first of all
i feel like like sex shouldn't be like
hold against the held against them yeah
just to punish them i feel like that's
just i feel like that's
do you think it's like a duty as a wife
not a duty but i mean like
okay if you're not sexually attracted
then um why the [ __ ] are you married
yeah but i'm saying like i think like as
a wife it kind of is your duty to be
honest having sex with your husband's
old school tradition type of thinking
yeah yeah probably maybe it is inflicted
over the generation she's traditional
already
first of all you don't have a mic right
now but i wouldn't that's why i don't
like the word duty because
you can't be like oh because you're
married to this person you owe sex
i think it's your own but i think you
kind of do though like you kind of
well with marriage so yeah like
like if you're if you're if you're let
me finish if you're getting married if
you're getting married like that's
that's part of marriage is sex so i like
i do think as a wife that is your duty
to your husband like to have sex with
him just like i think it's his duty too
like i think it's vice versa but i think
like both parties are gonna have a hard
time staying faithful if like one person
is withholding it it's just like women
do it more i think if like you want to
hold up your agreement like if for
example like just because the other
person maybe isn't hold up they're gonna
mean agreement why step out when you
could talk to them about it and have
actual conversation about it yeah you
should have a conversation it has to be
a conversation
instead of just stepping out in the
first instance
like i think that's where a lot of
cheating but i think women
cowards but i think women should know
that if you withhold sex from a man
you're going to find it somewhere else
holds it from a woman but that's where
also if he's withholding it from me that
means he's having sex somewhere
but if she reported does that mean she's
having sex elsewhere it could be too it
could be it could i'm not saying it
always is but it could be on that as
well that's why i'm saying like you know
communication is key everywhere it's 100
it really is like you just need to like
you know tell your partner what you're
comfortable with doing what you're what
they're comfortable doing with you
what do you guys want to agree with each
other to do with anyone else
otherwise you know why the hell else are
you in a relationship or married to each
other what the [ __ ] is that for
come on no
do you guys think that okay this is la
last question of the night okay last
question of the night
do you do you think that
if a man should be able to divorce a
woman if let's say like i get married
right and i gain a hundred pounds
and he's no longer attracted to me so
i'm i'm gonna look like a different
person
do you think he has a right to divorce
her or vice versa for a man and woman
yeah sure we could do vice versa
to divorce like i said there have to
have been many steps to divorce a man or
a woman get to that point so a man's
just gonna see his woman getting fat
and just not saying anything and then
wait till she gets to i don't know
however
yeah
so
would you guys
would you guys have a problem then if a
guy said to you hey like i love you
but you're getting but you're gaining
weight like you've gained 20 pounds the
last six months if you keeps going on to
this route
then like i i don't see us staying
together but he's honest with you he's
giving you the opportunity to lose it so
at least he's being honest i would say
this as a man right yeah if a man
men and women forget men men and women
should find each other attractive they
should find each other attractive
sexually right that's the main key of
keeping the spark in your relationship
and if somebody is um
if if you know your partner
is
not finding you attractive because of a
certain thing it's on you as a man or a
woman to say okay cool
i need to try and get that person that
i've committed to
to find me attractive again men or women
doesn't really matter do you know what i
mean yep
and
that it just made me think about um
how
women
will
and maybe some men do it but i haven't
heard that in that type of situation but
women will
do the go to the nine to get a man but
once they've gotten them they'll die
back and they won't they won't do what
they did to get them and the man's like
wait this is what i was expecting
you
you changed
and so i think that
that's
kind of similar but what you were saying
like the conversation and or what pearl
was saying how he says hey you've gained
some weight i would respect that and if
i didn't if yeah i took it and i was
like you know what i'm not getting no
way i'm just a little yeah
and
i gained more weight more weight and i
was not and like yeah not smart about it
or just
um naive about it and he was like you
know what i told you and you didn't take
the steps to change so is it with
anything i would respect it too to be
honest i mean i think like after you
have a kid like give me a couple months
after the kid
like more than a couple months
but like
i don't know i feel like i see a lot of
girls like the second they get a ring
just like let themselves like they gain
so much weight
and i'm like
yeah even even in a relationship because
they feel like they've got what they
want yeah but i feel like also men
encourage that as well like there are a
lot of men yeah that's true this is not
even exciting because they don't want
their woman being attracted to other men
they don't want their women to be it's
an eager thing right
yeah
they will want their women to get bigger
because they don't want their woman
being attractive sorry they don't want a
woman being attractive to other men but
the other the other but do those same
men get angry about those women gaining
weight no like because they like it
they've encouraged you yeah they want
you to be
they want you to be unattractive to
others
there's also men that lie to women and
say like that like they're attracted to
their wife when they're really not
anymore and they're not like how many
guys do you think really have the balls
when they're girls gaining weight that
they love to like say that depending on
i was that guy really you said that to a
girl i was that guy if when i when my
partner was gaining weight i said listen
babe
you're getting a little weight
do you know what i mean
like i was the devil
really yeah like
i was lying but but the thing is let me
make that
but let me but let me tell you something
right
women
lie to other women they lie to their
friends and so
when
go on
no this happened someone on our team i i
said look it i would i said i'm trying
to lose 20 pounds you don't need to lose
20 pounds i'm like look i used to be 20
pounds lighter i was hotter than you
weren't hotter than why i'm like i know
what like
and that goes back to what i was saying
it was in one of my vlogs
i don't want to like because she's
really nice i like her like people like
i know you know her yeah but i'm just
like why do we like why do we lie like i
think it's because like we just you know
we want each other to feel good
especially when you
don't know them that well
and
that's when it's harder to be more
truthful
and so you know like obviously i'm
getting telling you a little more i
think i can be a little much with you
but like i also haven't known you like
from yeah or from your future you know
but
um i think from what she was trying to
do is just you know make you feel good
also we're a little drunk
you know a lot of things are coming into
play oh i get it i i think it's like we
have
a natural like inclination to not hurt
each other's feelings for sure which
brings me on the lives because guys guys
will see the guy and be like bro like
your lips [ __ ] dry bro
like get some [ __ ] like no i'm saying
nobody like get some [ __ ] comics or
some [ __ ]
like i mean we're okay with that but if
a woman says that to another woman
mm-hmm it's like the world like the
world ended and i think it is
because
when it comes to
like we're talking about weight when it
comes to weight and women or just
certain things in women
if you talk about it in a negative way
or if you say like hey like um
it's like
when it comes to that there's there
hasn't
been a way to like that's been expressed
right to teach us hey it's okay to
out of a loving way tell your friend
that they are doing something wrong
that's when
that's why
i say that when women cheat they ain't
gonna say nothing cause it's like oh
they're not gonna be like girl like you
cheating on him
and they're gonna be like go ahead girl
exactly
and
you can do better than me anyway girl
yeah exactly he ain't no good
and then he said
and then you said when um
you had said that to your partner and
she got upset
that goes back to what i was saying
earlier how you
accountability in yourself and taking
what how that person says it
and how you how you take it and so
people say they want people to be honest
right
but when they are honest they can't take
the honesty
and the thing is as a as men we don't
understand that it's like because we're
honest with our friends and like we
speak honestly yeah when it comes to
woman it's like
when you go back to
do women want a man that wants to lie
they say oh men are liars
they're lies because they're lying
they're lying
like we lied to you because you can't
take the truth or do men also also not
give women the opportunity to take that
truth so you're not thinking so second
you said men like men don't men don't
tell the truth because women can't take
it right am i wrong a lot of women can't
take it okay not all but a lot of women
okay i'm going to talk about exceptions
yeah there are actually a lot of women
that can take the truth but men are a
lot of men are coward and that's just
facts i agree with that that's a lot of
facts but you have to understand that
but understand that men yeah
men essentially are very biological
biological creatures so
they're thinking about at the end of the
day getting sex from you
at the end of the day they're thinking
about getting sick
so they're thinking what can i say or do
to still get sex
and if they know that if they need to
keep you happy and not and lie to you to
get sex
a lot of men will do it but a lot of men
can get sex elsewhere but the reason why
just me personally the reason why people
say that me personally i'm quite
controversial
i'm not gonna lie to you i'm like yo
i don't care if about getting sex from
you i'ma tell you the truth ah but the
thing is the last ten guys
have lied to you
the last 10 guys have lied to you
because they want to get sex from you
yeah do you understand so when you come
across me
it's like
oh
oh my god this guy he's a misogynist
it's like no the last 10 guys told you
what they wanted to tell you because
they wanted to get in your panties my
dear mm-hmm i'm not going to tell you
that because i want to i might want to
get your panties but i don't care but
i'm still going to want to tell you the
truth
and whatever happens after that happens
after that do you know what i mean yeah
and you know
and it's funny
well and it's funny because i feel like
men would probably have more success
with women if they were more honest
because because we don't respect it we
can tell if you're just gassing us up
that's what a day is especially right
well that's why nowadays um like if a
guy is into you so soon and he's like
all in like right away we don't we're
like why well like what's going on here
you already know hold the [ __ ] up
like what's going on where are you i'm
putting an effort into conversation yeah
i think it's women generally like we
were talking about women generally they
don't even want
generally
want a guy who's got options
i know that's why they don't want a guy
who ain't got no women
you don't think so
no
no i i'm i'm saying for me personally
yeah um i mean
i want an attractive dude see what
you're an attractive dude will come with
women that if you if you think a guy's
attractive mm-hmm there are other women
out there right
yeah no there are other there are okay
there are other women that think that
you want you want
you don't you want a guy that no one
else wants no
no oh dude
women generally don't want a guy who's
not attractive to other women they want
a guy who is attractive to other women
but they feel like they got it
[Music]
um
as a guy
as a guy he wants a woman who's
attractive
but he wants a woman it's kind of yeah
he wants a woman who's attractive
but he doesn't want a woman who's been
for the streets if that makes sense
does that make sense like he wants a
woman who maybe knows a little thing
maybe knows a little bit
a little bit like a little bit but you
know a guy wants a guy wants a woman
that he can
mold no
so what i have heard is that you know
what you have heard what had happened
was
oh god sorry
excuse me you're excused but going
i'm sorry let me say let me
excuse you
um so what i have heard right go on is
you know like you know men like the same
thing as what we just described except
you know they want the woman to be you
know innocent
you know like
oh like i just want one person i just
want this like just basically just
wanting one man
basically never having had like not
never having sex but just like in it
more innocent yeah
more innocent
no not a whole basically being
experienced yet not having any type of
experience so can you explain that to me
um
so
okay so a guy wants a woman who has
maybe
excuse me who has maybe had experience
yes
intrigued other guys
like to want them yeah but she hasn't
gone there if that makes sense because a
guy that wasn't once a woman who's
attractive mm-hmm right that other guy
that is in demand but she doesn't he
doesn't want to know that she's been in
all of those
do you feel like those girls like
exist like they're common yeah probably
not in these days yeah yeah okay because
i've always heard that like in all the
like dating channels they're like they
don't want a girl that's too hot because
if she's too hot like there's no there's
no way do you know
you know i say to men i would say
men don't understand the value in
i don't want to be like go ahead i don't
want to be like why yeah
i don't want to say you fail anyway
men don't understand the value in the um
mediocre looking woman
who has values
does that make sense
like
men have
gone in these days and times they've
gone for the most
instagram model 10 number 10 she's got
breasts she's got ass she's got all of
this kind of stuff
right but they have they have
negated the
quote-unquote
six
on the scale right he has good values
and that is the woman that is going to
be your long-term partner you know the
woman that is 10 10
10 out of 10 that every man's looking at
and she knows every man is looking at
her right
he's
thinking oh this guy's in my inbox this
guy's in my dms this guy's in
that is not the woman that you want to
go for as a long-term partner
it's the woman that would be good to
look at
and women don't understand that
guys will see that woman
and like her picture
what the 10 10 instagram model
like the picture you don't think
anything but
he ain't trying to take that woman for
his wife
he's trying to take the woman
there's a difference between yeah
attractive there's that has good morals
well there's no i mean like that's
that's the type of guy there's there's a
difference between like sexual attention
and relationship attention i understand
that did you have something you wanted
to add eileen i feel like you're getting
kind of frustrated
no your body language is arms crossed i
know that's just that's just how i like
she's getting cut off a lot sorry
i'm just not very much of a vocal person
i feel like but um vocalize
um once you
[ __ ] you're saying so i can't i don't
remember because you were saying
something and they just had it something
on the top of my head did it was it
was it was it about he was saying that
like like men value purity more
like yeah
yeah like they want something like that
they want a girl that hasn't slept with
like too many guys basically yes so like
but you guys want women that have the
experience yet you still want that
purity
so where is that that doesn't make sense
exactly that's going to be i agree with
you it doesn't make sense yeah you can't
you can you can't have a pure woman that
hasn't experienced anything that doesn't
make sense why does someone that exp has
had experience make them not pure
like what defines purity in your eyes
i define that for me as me as an
individual me as me as me yeah you um
i don't look at i don't look at people
in that type of i don't look at me
i'm talking about i'm talking about me
as an individual well it's like it's
it's genetics like they're biologically
predispositioned to want a woman that's
pure because they want to ensure
paternity so so biologically like it's
the same way like we want a guy that
makes more money than us because before
we needed a guy that was more competent
than us to take care of us and like who
wants to be the guy that you're more
competent than like that's not
you want to feel protected yeah yeah and
that's like like like that would be like
men calling us gold diggers it's like us
like saying to them oh it's wrong for
you wanting a pure girl like they're
biologically wired to want that
you know no question like can most guys
get it which is why back in the day yeah
chastity and purity was
you know it was um it was it was a thing
a woman who was a virgin was a thing
wait i have a question would you would
you date a girl that was a virgin and
like wait till you were married with her
would you want to i would that's what
i've noticed but okay
you're 40 years old i'm full yeah
doesn't matter how many people she slept
with if you were
single and like what 20 something would
you would you wait
like to have sex with somebody yes
probably if i was like in my 20s yes
because now
now i've experienced more the world you
know i mean i'm like do you know what
i've noticed so they always i was
talking to do you know donovan sharp is
yeah
so on his show like he was saying like
the
like
men
like want like the ideal is a virgin
right but what i've noticed is like high
value guys like don't like seem to care
about that because they'll over a
certain age like guys are just like
whatever like they don't want to grow
this for the streets but they don't even
like
we don't that's why i've noticed like
those guys don't really end up with like
like virgins a lot of the times like
even like the celebrities like they
could have whoever and kanye was just
dating like who yeah
and he married kim kardas but like it
just seems like over a certain level
like unattainable
um it's an unattainable dichotomy
between
someone who is not a whole but not a
virgin yeah
yeah yeah
it doesn't actually make yeah if you
look at it seriously it's that guys want
a woman who's not a whole but not a
virgin yeah do you know what i mean it's
always like they don't have this it
doesn't make sense really do you know
what i mean like if we're honest with
ourselves like they have the experience
of a hoe
but then you know they're close to the
version but
if you're closer to the virginity scale
a guy will think ah
okay i can take her and kind of mold her
into what i kind of want yeah but we
don't want a full woman who's for the
streets that's interesting what defines
for the streets like is it because of
her experience you know who the women
are for the shoes
only because
go on like a hole in it like somebody
no i'm so experienced so basically if a
woman's got more than like
careful
be careful thirty thirty men that she's
left with i'm like i feel like a lot of
people define experience for how maybe
like because i feel like you can't be
experienced with men like you can know
what you're doing and everything with
like three women
or maybe
men want women who are semi-expert as
i'm saying it's it's it's an
unattainable yeah it generally it's an
unattainable thing right
i'm not i'm not i'm not gonna lie to you
like but the thing is women want men
who have been experienced would you want
a virgin is a man to me no no but yeah
but he doesn't always talk about it
based
no but i get that but generally there's
a woman want a man who doesn't know what
he's doing
based on experience like what i want
from a man in general like as a whole
like it's not based on experience
like how men would say like you know
they want like a more
pure woman
like that's not my
standard
do you know what i mean so what do you
want is do you want a man who's had
experience in the bedroom or not it
doesn't like it doesn't really matter to
me like do you want a virgin so if you
had a man who was a virgin didn't know
what the hell you didn't know where your
clitoris was
that he didn't know nothing
bring it to the extreme i think she just
means like you know not someone that's
like necessarily like a professional in
bed you know maybe someone that you know
like he's been around the town yeah he
doesn't even but not necessarily
because it's i thought it was like
because you would find a man who had
more experience yeah but it doesn't even
matter you would find a man who had more
experience
over
if there's a guy like and i know this
goes against like what the man of spear
says but if there's a guy and i know he
slept with like a bunch of girls i know
i'm like i'm good on that i'm no
what if he's got a hundred women that he
slept with but you know not one of them
i don't know them um i probably
you good how would you even know about
it
no but what if you had that conversation
wouldn't you have that conversation
absolutely i'm nosy i always
um
but he's saying listen i love you like
we're in a relationship this is you
i would be okay because here's my thing
i
i get very like
nervous so like like with guys because
like what are the odds you can go from
like that many girls to one like i you
know what i mean like that would make me
like more skeptical i don't think it
would like write them off but i just
think that you're we're creatures of
habit so if your habit is sleeping with
like that many girls in a year like what
are the odds you can go from that to
zero like
emotional connection with them because
you found you yeah am i that like
i still think men are biologically wired
a certain way so i still think you are a
product of your habits just like i think
like i understand vice versa like if
you're with a girl that has like cheated
in every relationship to like like you
know she might do it again if the guy's
used to sleeping around like what are
the odds he's gonna stop your resume
your resume yeah yeah you're done
right and probably what you're going to
do in the future yeah right yeah i mean
so so it's more like like i'll be
attracted to those guys but i'm always
like oh god like like you you would i
always say i always say don't ruin my
journey
you have experience yeah that's true
because we're attracted to like then
otherwise because with experience it
brings confidence it brings a certain
swagger it means a certain
energy do you understand
exactly so
so women generally don't they're not
attracted to virgin men
that's not what we're saying i'm muted
how many haircuts
so she's sick on the fact that you can
go get water if you want
sorry go on
do you agree that women are generally
attracted to men with experience yeah i
would say that yeah because it's just
because
it's just like a like you said a
confidence they have a little swagger
they have about that they're going to
walk into a room is like yeah
i know i can get you right because of my
track record so i ain't about to shy
away from you exactly
but women aren't generally attracted to
men
with no experience
men attracted to women with less
experience yeah if that makes sense
now and i'm talking about for a
long-term partner i'm not talking about
for a short term are we just gonna [ __ ]
and all that kind of stuff yeah
material let's say to women who have had
less experience less experience yes
100
sometimes less experience also means
wife material am i wrong yeah does that
feel like that's what he's saying okay
yeah
i feel like you contrasted that no no
yeah let's experience a man who knows a
woman who has had less penises inside
her vagina yeah is going to be his wife
more wife material so sorry are you okay
more wife material right 100 okay 100
but a woman who's had
he's got 150 men that she's slept with
men aren't like yeah that's wifey mm-hmm
even if she brings other qualities to
the table it doesn't matter what do you
think because that's about the body
count
but do you think i will let you i will
be honest men are
that's why women lie about their body
count and that's why men ask about the
body count mm-hmm women lie about their
bodyguards i could ask all women here
about their body count you would lie
right now
but
right there you go you're bad
ellen
sorry i still have hiccups but do you
not think that you know
oh my god i'm guess i'm not good but do
you not think that like you know it's
like the same vice versa what do you
mean
like you know
obviously
oh my god like we know like if a man
were to have experience
and you know like me listen to this but
you know maybe the woman's looking for
something else
okay
that's what i'm saying like you know
maybe like the woman is looking for
something more serious and because she
knows
that
you've that you've hooked up with like
you know all these multiple women
whatever yeah but that's attractive to a
woman generally do you think so like to
have
multiple sexual partners is attractive
do you know why
it's because a woman wants to know that
a man is experienced they want to know
that he knows what he's doing i feel
like that that is a hit or miss
so all right all right so then my
question becomes now my question becomes
do you want a virgin do you want a
virgin man well obviously not but i'm
not saying that i want someone that's
[ __ ] like 200 men i mean woman oh my god
i'm sorry
that would be
that would be a man who's gay
but i would say that but but but there's
there's there's bio there's biological
reasons for the reasons we feel the way
we feel so the reason that women i'm
gonna i'm gonna mute you
the reason the reasons why women are
attracted to men that have slept with
more women is because like we want it
was pre-selection so before like we if a
guy had a lot of girls that was a sign
that he could take care of all those
women
so like we are biologically
predispositioned to like a man that has
been with like more girls and i think
that it's just
drinks drink some water i think that
for women
to have someone that's a virgin it's
just like a
oh it's like a sigh like dang
they don't know what they're doing
because right it takes for a man it
doesn't take much to
please them for women it takes more
right he needs to know what the hell
he's doing right he doesn't have
experience is going to be like okay let
me
you're going to have to teach yeah yeah
it's just going to take longer and i
feel like more females don't want to
take that process to
like to
help them out in that and
for men it's like
they don't
not related but you know maybe we should
no but the thing is like there's a
what's a term turning someone out like
you turn someone out yeah but also
define that for me no like a man there's
someone else
no i thought no okay i could could be
wrong but i thought it was a man who
gets with a woman who's kind of like
i'm shy
and he kind of makes her into like a
quote-unquote freak if that makes sense
okay okay yeah yeah
like turn in some like so men
would prefer
to quote-unquote make that happen
then a woman would try and make a man
into
do you know i mean a woman doesn't want
to teach a man
yeah
yeah how to have sex because it's just
it's so much more for a female and it's
like
it's like
i might as well take you to sex ed to
teach you how to please me
exactly so men
understand that and so when men are
having
multiple sexual experiences in general
they understand that yeah so when they
get to a woman and they've had multiple
sexual experiences they understand that
that's actually attractive to women
now
i'm not saying that
having multiple sexual experiences is a
good thing or a bad thing i'm just
saying
us as men we understand that if we come
to a woman
and we don't know what we're doing
she's probably going to be like
the [ __ ] is this guy yeah
there's biological reasons why we feel
the way we feel and we can't help like
you can't you can't really there's
biological reasons that we feel the way
we feel so we can't like necessarily
help it guys can't necessarily help that
they want more pure women especially in
this day and age i've had a lot of guys
wish they could turn that off
there are no pure women
oh god
okay
wait
like generally in the western world like
women like
no i don't generally think that men
i don't think women generally think men
are pure
and i don't generally think that women
think
sorry men don't think women are pure and
women don't think men are generally pure
in this day and age you know i mean the
western culture yeah i don't yeah no
like if it's when someone says oh i'm
single i'm like
how many men you got your dms
but i don't lie like
yeah that's not just how many men you
[ __ ] that's available when was the
last time you had sex that's irrelevant
you don't think you don't think you
don't think that's relevant to a guy to
a guy let me let me okay okay okay okay
you keep cutting me off but it's
actually irritating me so
um no i'm saying you don't think it's
relevant to a guy that's asking you on a
date and he's courting you if you're
sleeping with someone else
i literally think it is
because because he's putting all if
you're not sleeping with the new guy
yeah if you're not sleeping with the new
guy he's putting all this time energy
and resources into you just to find out
you're giving it to the other guy for
free you know how irritating that is to
men
then they're like why am i doing all
this yeah yeah like like she understands
there's no because you're about to say
it depends on the relationship there's
no no you you would be upset if you're
going out of your way to spend time with
this dude and he's over here doing
whatever with this girl
no no it doesn't matter what type of
relationship it is if someone if someone
is putting in time you would be upset if
a friend is if you're putting in all
this time for this friend buying them
gifts showing how much you appreciate
them and they're receiving and you're
saying yeah you're and then they're
doing this for their friend over here
and they're doing everything you're
doing for them they're doing for this
friend you're like wait why can't you do
that for me and i'm giving you that yeah
but you're doing this for this person
over here that don't really care about
you but i care so
psychology
but why do you keep arguing the
exception like why
no because no it doesn't because we're
talking about in general there's
exceptions to every goddamn rule in
other words we're going to be here all
day if you just are like what about that
exception and that except like why do
women do this they do this women always
always the exception women will argue
the five percent of the argument when
there's a whole 95 percent like first
in their own personal situation no but
all right so
if you were if you're a woman and you're
on a date with a man and this is a
difference between i think between men
and women
a woman's on date with a man
man's on a date with a woman
the woman asks when's the last time you
had sex
and the man says
and then says
a week ago
right
a woman's thinking
who the [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
a week ago
i like you on this date right now like
i'm trying to get to know you who you
are and if a woman on a date says to a
man you had sex a week ago and man's
thinking [ __ ] this [ __ ]
this is the last date we're going on
wait never happened
like if a woman would just say that's
what he's thinking i'm not saying it's
correct what i'm saying yeah because
because again there's biological reason
yeah i'm like is that i fought this say
the same thing as him wait wait guys
let her go so if a woman were
oh sorry i still have hiccups but so
like say like oh
yeah i just had us had sex with a woman
like just a week ago and then the woman
you're on the same same date with you're
like she says oh yeah i just you know
same me too same day would you see her
differently from the way you see
yourself
100
yeah because because
because we've got over this we have
biological reasonings for the way we
feel how we feel there are double
standards and we are not the same
double centers don't exist like we get
into close
we don't have to pay on dates we get
into clubs for free we like we there's a
million scholarships for female like
female [ __ ] you know
we only we only complain about the few
double standards that there are and this
double standard is don't have sex with a
guy within a week that you're going on a
date with a new guy like that's that
crazy guys
it's not crazy
it's not
if a guy knows that you've had sex him
in the last week and he's on a date with
you he's already said you know what he
[Music]
but they're not thinking that it's going
to be a long term thing they think that
they're not thinking oh this is someone
who i could potentially be going into a
relationship with yeah
well and it's bad for women too because
then women like half the time like the
girl's sleeping with the guy she's
actually in love with and then like
wasting all these other guys times and
she's not she can't even be open with
the new guy because she's still like how
is she supposed to be open with these
new guys and give him a chance when
you're you're sleeping with this old guy
that you actually want you know what
he's thinking he's thinking so there's a
guy that you had sex with a week ago
know that you're on a date with me
he probably doesn't which means
you're probably going on dates with
other guys too while you're [ __ ] this
guy yeah they call themselves daddy's
yeah that is what the guy's thinking
i'm telling you yeah that's what he's
thinking yeah and but i think this will
pay off like oh no we okay yeah here we
go
because women are wired differently for
men yeah because women want to know to
some degree
that you got someone who
um is looking at you they want to know
that you've got someone who is kind of
feeling you so they can be the one
to trump all those other women yeah we
want to feel like we got we won
yeah yeah yeah yeah like why would i
want to go no
why would i want a guy that no one else
wants like actually
the bottom of the barrel yeah
you know when you cook rice do you cook
rice yeah you know that
you know when it's like burnt at the
bottom okay oh my god you've got that
guy
yeah you got the burnt rice at the
bottom you know why i think women's like
dating advice is so bad because because
women will say like oh you'll you're the
prize honey like but like if it's a guy
you want you're actually not the prize
because he can find a million of you you
know what i mean like beauty is common
and they expect like these these like
super attractive guys to like court them
like they're the only one and i'm not
saying like chase after guys that aren't
interested in you but like they always
tell girls like you're the prize don't
have to do anything
reject him and he'll still come after
you like i'm telling you a guy that
knows his worth right knows that he's
got
um
a thousand women that want him
and you have to be the one
i'm telling women you have to be the one
that makes him think
what is different about this girl than
the other thousand women
no no this woman's
ticking other boxes that the other
thousand women aren't aren't ticking
do you know what i mean yeah
because women essentially want a want
that like yeah i was saying they want
that top 15 10 guy yeah
a guy would go literally like what we've
got here co-op yep a guy would walk into
co-op
see a woman in the kit on on
on a checkout and be like oh she's nice
and if that woman
ticks the boxes that he wants as a woman
he'd marry that woman
she doesn't have to be a woman who
she has to be she has to take certain
boxes he doesn't care if she is a
ceo of a company or if she is working on
checkout if she ticks those boxes he's
down
like that
that was always something hard for me
because i have a really strong work
ethic like my whole life that's like the
one thing that i've always been
complimented on this i work like very
hard at what i do and it is hard to find
a guy that like works harder than me to
be honest like it's it's difficult and
it's always harder because
like men don't really value that as much
as women do well not hard work yeah yeah
like work ethic
i don't
you just said if a girl is working at
like like the checkout
hang on
i'm saying i i want to understand that
i'm saying what men have great work
ethic yes they do right and like i'm
saying like like as a girl like i i work
very hard like i'm always like since i
was a kid that was the one thing like
i've always been complimented right i'm
a very hard worker and i said like
sometimes it's hard like in dating
because that isn't really valued to men
i feel like like i feel like it's
working yeah yeah they don't
right right exactly but it's like um
i don't know sometimes you kind of wish
it was but it's just not how it is no
it's not i understand that it's really
not okay but it's because it's like like
then the guys that have that work ethic
you know you know what that's valuable
to you
other women yeah i know i know
it's valuable valuable to you yeah it's
not very good oh i know
to more to you than it would be to ask
yeah
yeah and it's different
we don't see sorry go on continue though
no that was it like i was just saying
like and then it's like it can be harder
and dating like as a girl that like
works hard because you can't you can't
turn that off that's just how that's how
i am right and so but then it's like
you're you're competing for an even
smaller pool of guys no you work very
hard you like incredibly like i see you
work all the time
but like it's like you're competing for
like a smaller a smaller group of guys
because who wants to be with a guy that
who wants to be the guy that doesn't
work as hard as you yeah right yeah yeah
right right ambition so the man that
you're looking for yeah needs to have
the same work ethic as you know yeah
yeah i would say ambition is a good word
or he's even just like um but gonna be
better than
what yeah what you were served or what
you were even getting well i always say
i would marry a coach if he was a coach
and like that's not a high paying career
but if he he yeah if he he's passionate
about and he works hard at it i don't
care if he's a musician a coach like i i
have less money than me that's fine i
have family money i don't care like i
don't so so what does that matter to me
i just want to know like
i'm a millionaire [ __ ]
not not now i'm not like a brat like i
don't have anything now but i know like
at some point i'll inherit something
right
i think is how hard he works and how
much he wants to invest to make that
thing that he's working for yeah
yeah yeah
what's the point of him maybe working
for that thing if he's you know just
there just to like do the conventional
[ __ ] like oh let me just get this like
to just just get a check yeah like you
don't want to make it better than what
you already got like
whatever yeah
yeah yeah
it's not 100 hypergamy it's just like
you know it's the motivation and just
like wanting to make something that you
have you want a guy that works harder
it's like women women date up so so
hypergamy just means we day up so i want
to date a guy that works harder than me
or at least as hard as i do so that
that's hypergamy
and maybe maybe i'll be one of these
like 35 and single and childhood
i am not
what if you met a guy
on your level the same level as you
that's as motivated the standard that
you are yeah okay
what's the case that be good for you
would that be okay
yeah i think i think i feel like that
would because you know we'd be there to
push each other to be
like better than what we are
i think that's what i want i don't i
don't want to be so i stop hiccups but i
don't want to just be in this steady
pace and be like okay
like let's just keep going so do you
think do you feel like you're at a
steady pace
right now i i'm i think i'm going up you
know i was and you've got a guy that's
on the same
you have a guy on the same level that's
reaching for something more yes whatever
you're thinking and feeling and reaching
for you find a guy on that same level
yes is that good enough for you yes or
do you want the guy that's higher than
that
right i wouldn't you know
socially
and economically
he's a business owner he's a you know i
mean he's he's doing a little he's he's
doing a little bit more well than you
he's not at university he's
made his business he's done all this
kind of stuff he's already established
himself okay like
do you prefer that guy
over the guy that's
on your level
i would say you know i wouldn't mind
having someone at my same level and
working towards this same goal
and at that point if i find the same two
people i would say that depends on how
much
chemistry i have with that person to
find something you know i think without
i don't know you right
i think you choose a guy
who is higher up you think so why
because
hypergamy is a thing
and so hypergame is a thing and so you
think of me as a havoc all right all
right so so
so okay so you got two guys that you
like right
just what if i click with
you click with the guy that's
normal let's say for whatever better
term normal then you click with the guy
who is
a business owner multi-millionaire maybe
etc etc who are you picking
if you were saying everything else was
the same yeah if everything you clicked
with this guy and you clicked with that
guy like
wise family-wise everything you click
with them both the same
higher up then hypergame is a thing you
haven't men it's the same thing with men
100 percent it's like everyone everyone
i'm not saying it's a bad thing i'm not
everyone wants the best deal they can
get exactly i just the difference is
women lie to each other and say they can
get a better deal than they can get
that's the difference where men will men
will be honest to be like look she's out
of your league bro
what not a lot of men like a lot of them
men will be honest with each other like
no no
oh my god yes they do more than if it oh
my god
we will tell them if they've got a
[ __ ] booger in their nose we will
tell them if the girl that they're
seeing ain't the right girl for them we
would tell them
everything
because
we were telling if they're getting fat
bro bro you're getting fat
bro like you were guy in gym like what
the [ __ ]
but the thing is
no we would do no they do i'm lying the
thing is women
don't tell women lie to other women they
look at body positivity let's just start
there come on
lizzo is a female she's she
shot chris hemsworth we all know damn
well chris hemsworth is not responding
to lizzo he's going to go find them
lizzo is a fat individual right by the
standards people like yeah buzzy body
positivity it's like come on like we
just like we lie
you lied to other women that's what
women do they lie to other women
i say women do it more than the men do
right
yeah
then do you think i look fat and there's
no girl you look good
exactly oh my god your eyes look good oh
my god your ass
shut up stop [ __ ] lying
should not be like stop lying
no a guy will say bro change your shirt
that shirt don't look right bro like
change of jeans change your shoes that
that that don't all right say that to
like a look around a man
no but i'm saying women
are friends of course we will because we
have that relationship say the same
thing
you will tell your friend that she looks
fat in a dress
like she's my sister like [ __ ] that
don't help me please
guys one at a time one at a time call my
friends out they will say yes eileen has
told me to take that [ __ ] off and put
something else the [ __ ] on will you
would you tell me the thing is in your
head you're probably thinking she's
probably telling me that because she's
jealous the way i look and blah
blah blah
your lashes are not even on properly
your lashes are not lashing yeah
no way my girl yeah she doesn't cheat on
my sister she'll be like abby like do
the highlight but i'll blend your
contour blend your foundation like your
next showing that's what she will be
like i feel like would she tell you that
she's that you're fat no you look like a
little bit waiting together yes hundred
percent
okay okay okay okay actually eileen i
have a question have you noticed anyone
on our team gaining weight since they've
been here so they've been here no
actually
when you say your team what does that
mean
we're on the same volleyball oh are you
on the same team
yeah i'm her outfit yeah
my
yeah
but i don't even know what the hell that
means but okay
he's the one that slams it down london
you slam me down yeah yeah yeah
yeah
we're on the same volleyball team we're
in the same basketball team
oh but no we both turn it down i'm not
the setter [ __ ] no we both she's the
middle hitter i'm on the left front so
we both yeah
um honestly i don't think anyone on our
team has gained weight i feel like if
anything like we've just
honestly
if i'm being honest there's people that
have not been there
i can't tell if they've gained weight or
not because i haven't seen them okay
would you pull them aside one-on-one and
tell them to show up have you done that
actually message in our group chat
i told you yeah but you don't tell the
people you're talking to to their face
one-on-one but did i
yeah i feel like you you might you may
as well
okay well but you know i feel like i
don't need to be because i already say
who is showing up why they aren't
showing up yeah and i'm questioning why
isn't everyone else oh
i feel like that's not necessary for me
to say it because
people can tell what pisses me off by
the total eileen i i agree i'm not
arguing with you but do you know what
i'm saying though i'm saying like men
will just pull the dude inside and say
what like why why the [ __ ] aren't you
coming where us we will put it in a
group chat and like
you don't think
because you know from the bathroom
a lot of people don't show up to the
lifts okay or to the
no it's not actually optional but
optional practices but they never
[ __ ] show up and they give [ __ ]
excuses as well but they don't
no one says anything to each other you
don't think so no they don't they no i
know so okay okay
okay maybe you're right the messages
yes that's the thing about messages
we don't do that [ __ ] like i feel like
we just we just we just go to whoever it
is that we have a problem with and speak
the the real [ __ ] message i will say i
will say i don't like it's a certain
type of guy that does that like men men
are men are more like feminine today
because nowadays are becoming
sorry to say they're becoming [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah that's what i'm saying so
like that's probably men today are
becoming [ __ ]
so it go ahead
no sorry
they're becoming more effeminate they're
doing more effeminate behaviors they're
doing more things that women do and i'm
looking at them like bro what the hell
is that like why are you doing that like
that's not what we do like
the last time you said you don't even
see the difference between masculine and
feminine
yeah you do i think i respect it girl
girl
i do
um like i feel like i understand men are
built different to women like
biologically chemically like naturally
which i completely respect but i think
it's just
ignorant to disrespect a woman's hard
work and but do you know what it is
though every year
women today or the let's say the way in
which society is moving yeah women and
the quote-unquote feminist movement
are creating men
that women don't respect
what do you mean by that they're
creating the most bitch-made feminine
men in society they're telling men to be
in touch with their emotions they're
telling men to be more like women
they're telling men to be all this kind
of stuff women don't respect those kinds
of men
they don't respect them so so my
question no so my question is why would
you create a type of man that you don't
even want as a woman that doesn't make
any sense
but like when you say that like that's
like you're insulting like a woman
working hard for what they're gonna do
no working harder in fact a woman
working hard that's good but i'm saying
the whole movement that's going on
nowadays women are kind trying to create
men
that women in general don't respect okay
men women respect masculine men yeah
they respect men who are losing touch
with them in touch with their
masculinity they their leaders their
their providers all this kind of stuff
the feminist movement is creating men
that women don't respect so when these
men show up women are like these men are
soft these men are because you created
them you asked men to be like do you
guys agree with that
to an extent yeah yeah two next time
why would you create the types of men
that you don't actually want as a woman
i don't get it yeah i don't think that i
do not think that they're purposely like
trying to make
[ __ ] made men yeah well i think it's we
don't know what we want so like we say
we want the emotional availability but
if a guy's like crying all the time like
i'm like no thank you you're gonna be
like you're gonna be like
oh no
yeah but you're gonna be like why is
this guy so emotional yeah
so i'd say like sorry go ahead
oh no i was just gonna say um so is it
bad for um
for men to be
in touch with their i won't say feminine
femininity but be more emotional it's
not bad because both men and women have
a masculine feminine side
i'm saying
what has happened in in my personal
point of view is that women have asked
men for the past four decades
to be a type of man
and when men have been this type of man
they don't like it
generally women in general don't like it
and so
what is now happened is that men are
more in my personal point of view men
are more effeminate now yeah right
they're more effeminate
but the only reason why they are more
effeminate is because men
essentially want to get women yeah no no
because they make that way
to try and get women yeah because
they've listened to you they were like
what do what do you want okay cool
that's what you want i want to get a
[ __ ] okay cool i'll be that guy right
yeah and then so do it when they do it
women are like yeah like it's like
yo like what the [ __ ] yeah yeah it's
weird yeah it doesn't make sense do you
want to say something eileen
you seem like you want to say something
so no it's just
a lot of these things are just bringing
a lot of thoughts in my head i'm just
like you know it's not necessarily that
we want
men you know to be completely feminine i
think it's just more like
you know we would just like them to be a
little more considerate
yeah
no the only the the reason why i'm i've
in my personal point of view where women
want men to be more
effeminate is so women can control them
but i don't think it's the femininity
women want to con
this new generation of women wants to
control
of
um i don't think it's that we want to
win in the femininity i think it's just
more like
sorry continue continue
to understand like our perspective and
like you know you're [ __ ] making me
forget what the [ __ ] i'm about to say
just be more like considerate and like
understanding exactly
it's not like we want you guys to be
we're like
we're not like that
we don't want you guys to be like our
girlfriends or whatever
we just want you guys to understand why
we're saying some things and you know
why something sometimes you guys the way
you guys do things make us feel a
certain way okay
when you know we're on our [ __ ]
period and you say oh you feel this way
because you're on your period like [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] say that
just be like other you you're not
understanding how men think you're
really not understanding how men but
okay but then why should women always be
the people that try to understand what
you guys think why can't you guys try to
understand what the [ __ ] we're trying to
do because you don't know what the [ __ ]
you think from day to day
that's why why do you think that though
because we're [ __ ] nominated because
we're stupid
because you change your mind because
we're chemically different every single
day that is true like like chemically
like every single day we are different
ugh
you have a whole bunch that's a hard to
swallow right that's a hard pill to
swallow so like i was saying earlier on
in the conversation right is that if if
we understand that your period makes you
a certain way right
and you know that it pisses off this is
a soft forget that we're not we're not
thinking about that we're thinking about
we're on the receiving end of the
emotion of the period
right that's what we're thinking
but we're still human beings too right
so as human beings we're going to
respond in kind
to being i guess uh
lambasted
when it's lambasted when it comes to the
period right and we we understand we
know you as an individual we're saying
but hang on do you not like this on a re
on the 30 other days of the of the month
but
generally like when it comes to this
time you're something different so we're
going to let you know that you've become
different
on this time but saying that seems to be
a problem
and we don't get that because if you
were to tell us
that we're different
we would understand actually you know
what actually guys
on these seven days we're we're acting a
little bit [ __ ] up like like we're
acting like we know we're actually
[ __ ] up but you don't want to be told
that and that's what we don't understand
i think it's self-awareness comes into
play right um
[Music]
like i know that
chemically
if you think about it sometimes majority
of women are very
indecisive there's some that boom boom
boom can make a decision but it's
i understand what you're saying how many
times women i understand what you're
saying how women need to understand men
i think it's
there's when it comes to women like you
were saying chemically we are we think
different every day there may be a day
where we consecutively think the same
but
our bodies are going through a cycle for
30 plus date and it's a continuous thing
it's not something oh we just pause like
good i can think i can think properly i
can think clearly
it's
if you step outside of a woman's body if
you are a woman you step outside of your
body and you try to understand yourself
it's hard personally there's sometimes
i'm like
why why do i why do i do this why am i
thinking like this i'm trying to
understand when you cry over the
smallest thing i know
like what's going on i'm trying to
understand myself yeah and for men it's
just simple like that's what we do
that's how we live
don't understand like i
said i was saying this to be like kind
to you like i i don't understand why
yeah this way and so they're processed
and it comes out their mouth
you must be on your period and then be
like
yeah everyone's like
don't say that why did they take it that
way i'm just trying to process and i
outwardly process and then
it comes into like okay maybe i'm not
going to say that anymore and it's just
like
they keep it inside and it's like
does it both
no because well
because i know i know this i know it is
very i agree i know what she's saying
she's saying why would you do the same
thing if you get the same reaction every
single time you're right yeah like like
she's like why don't you keep doing it
but women will do the same thing but
women will do the same thing expecting a
different reaction too
because you know it's been so long but
then
but then it's been at least 30 days
are you telling me that every 30 days
we've just got to be in our guard we're
just like but we're parents coming we
just gotta be [ __ ] we don't know what
the [ __ ] gonna happen right now look
at me i'm not saying that's what you
need to [ __ ] expect but when you know
the girls on her thing like
why do you want to push well maybe
we're
[Music]
about men becoming more feminine right
yeah you are expecting men to act like
women
hang on women here women understand that
she's on a period yeah yeah she's
unknown
women understand that men don't get it
you just have to vocalize it we have
been here on this earth with women
for hundreds of thousands of years and
we still do not get it stop asking us to
be like your girlfriend stop asking us
to be like women we are men for a reason
that's all we're saying we're men for a
reason and the thing is if we weren't
men
you wouldn't even be attracted to us
because you know what i'm saying
you wouldn't even be attracted to us if
you were men why would you even mention
our period because it's it's
we are logical processes
because he's saying like that's how
that's how men are is they just they're
like trying to fix a problem so this is
the problem you're upset about something
and they're thinking okay how do i fix
it let me rationalize this oh she's on
her you're probably just on your period
honey calm down don't tell me to calm
down
like
like that that's them trying to
rationalize it so you you asking him to
understand you that's that's asking him
to be more feminine because that's not a
feminine trait right so you see this
light right there that's not a masculine
there's a light here right
if the light goes out a man is trying to
fix the light yeah we're not trying to
understand why the light is gone or
what the what the light felt like yeah
when it was gone we're not trying to
we're just like that's gone fix it
that's how we think right and i'm not
saying it's the right thing or the wrong
thing i'm saying that's how we're wired
and so when we're wired a certain way
when you're asking us to be more like
women you can have that conversation
about your period and how you feel and
how you think with your other female
friends you know what i'm saying we
don't get it because because we are
trying to we're trying to just fix
things if you come to a man and say
oh my god at work today
this happened and i felt this way we're
listening and we're like okay so we're
gonna do about it
what's gonna happen like what what are
we doing to make you not feel like that
yeah and that's why but the thing is you
came to him
wanting to just vent and make make him
know how you feel yeah does that make
sense like we're trying to fix it
you're trying to just express
we're trying to fix things and that's
why they're sometimes like are you sorry
okay
oh
you must be on your period because if
you're acting a certain way they're
trying to understand it
and if you say
no i'm not on my peer then they're like
okay then let me try to figure out what
why is this like if you're if you've
acted this way like this every month on
your period and it's like oh you and
when we start seeing a pattern when we
start seeing that pattern we're like ah
all right she's on my appearance that's
what we're thinking about
[Music]
it honestly like helped because i would
get [ __ ] like a couple days before my
period and he just wouldn't really take
it seriously
he's like oh she's just and at the time
at the time i'd be like mad i'd be like
take me seriously
until like three days later
and he's like oh she's just and then
like three days later i was like oh okay
sorry
right
the thing is we are okay with that as
long as you recognize that what's going
on
do you know what i'm saying like if you
recognize that you're feeling that way
because of your period we are okay with
that we're like
what is it i feel like it's a lot of
understanding like as a woman i feel
like even i've seen this a lot of them
like yeah okay i acknowledge it like if
a man was to check them about their
menstrual cycle and that's why that's
what affects their mood compared to if
it's like that's actually what they
really understand that that's what's
really affecting their mood that's just
really what's taking an impact on their
mood
do you know what i mean no i get it like
you can check me and i could know yeah
that's my menstrual cycle but i'm still
going to be defensive
compared white to white white
i don't know why i can't explain to you
why
compared to a situation where it's like
that's a fact and where are you having a
conversation about me and my partner
do you know what i mean like getting
defensive about it because it's
different
like i feel like a lot of women don't
acknowledge it like understand no way a
lot of them don't understand it compared
to acknowledging it do you know what i'm
saying
yeah don't come to us
because
you're going to get someone who wants to
fix the light
over someone who wants to understand why
the likes gone out
that's not realistic you're going to
talk to your guy about your problems
sometimes no but guys
and that's why i said men's spaces are
definitely needed
men's spaces are needed because men
understand how men interact with men and
how they communicate with men until okay
until until women
until women come into them hello
but i think it's right because men are
men yeah if an attractive woman comes in
everyone's like oh where there's a woman
there
because men are simple creatures to some
degree right but i'm saying men the
reason why men's spaces are actually
needed is because men understand how men
communicate yeah we understand how we
interact and so when but what happens is
when men are in men's spaces and they
start communicating the way they
communicate what happens with the
general women
that is toxic
that's toxic masculinity
that is
chauvinism
all and we're like we're just
being ourselves and honest
and that is what
a lot of this generation of
new modern day women and feminism and
whatever they don't understand we're not
trying to disrespect anybody we're not
trying to
undermine anybody we're not trying to
make you feel like you're less than a
human being but we do have our thoughts
and feelings in the way we express
ourselves that's all we're saying
yeah that's what i'm saying okay
okay guys sorry
no i need to read super chat
super chat
um okay i'm probably gonna end it on
that
um thank you guys all for coming i'm
gonna read the super chats and then
we'll you guys can like plug your stuff
um okay so the last super chat i think
oh gosh use a lot thanks guys
oh wow okay okay
um i'm
wait wait let's see if there's any okay
so sandra i'm with pearl anyone with a
pulse can get hiv man or woman if your
number number is in the triple digits
you're dangerous to sleep with triple
digits she just jumped right bro
this is crazy
in the manosphere there are a lot of
spheres it's a
it's a guy told you he's got 150 women i
slept with you you ain't gonna not sleep
with him
you can sleep with him i wouldn't no but
i wouldn't i wouldn't okay apparently
i'm not trying to get
it's like 150.
[Music]
exactly
i would say but i'm a number i'm a
numbers person like i'm not going to
wrap like you get the wrong std you
can't have kids i'm not risking that
wrong
bro got the wrong std right here
okay okay i have one more um
men have to have skills resources and
status to get sex from any woman but a
woman only needs box to get sex from a
man yeah that's true women are
hypergamous
it means that woman wants a man of
higher status income height strengths
etc a virgin woman chose low status
because no woman a virgin man chose low
status because no woman wants him woman
want the best man not a loser
five dollar super chat took care of some
terminally ill patient
not about to take care of somebody
because they made bad choices cancer is
different from diabetes thank you so
much sandra sandra you have been you're
like the super chatter
of the stream you've sent so many i
appreciate you so much same with you
maverick maverick s um has sent a bunch
too feminist movement tells people that
men are evil unless men are soft
emotional like women and members of the
lgbtq
uh maverick another one from you thank
you so much the issue here is that women
do not understand what men want women
don't understand themselves and women
want to change their emotions all the
time women don't even understand what
men are about
sorry
okay thank you guys so much i i don't
know how much we raised this stream but
this is a decent chunk of change
remember all donations are going towards
no i'm joking
don't play with me
all donations are going towards eight
mikes so then i can host eight people in
here i'm gonna get a wooden table and
extra camera angles so all money i
really appreciate it another way that
you can donate to the stream is actually
by purchasing a meal plan i'm on a meal
plan it's cooking with chris it's a link
in the description i've lost six pounds
two weeks get you one you can lose some
weight
um
and we're going to go around everyone's
going to say they're socials and any
last words so i'm starting with you
sarah uh yes thank you all for watching
uh my name is sarah garvey and my
socials are oh my god sarah garvey
on youtube let me spell it out for them
s a
r a
sarah g-a-r-v-e-y
on youtube um on instagram you've tagged
me right
is the black opinion which is my uh
um
podcast page
and on twitter i am both sarah garvey
again and a black opinion on twitter
that's about it and on tick tock sorry
tick tock i am sarah garvey as well you
won't be that you won't be there alone
they're gonna ban me
again thank you pearl i appreciate being
asked to be on this podcast and any
other podcast so thank you miss pearl
for inviting me um
my socials on instagram it's it's it's
your girl jess um
after it's and yeah there's a dot so
it's it's
[Music]
girl underscore jess and then on youtube
it's the same thing it's your girl dress
without the extra things but make sure
you put an apostrophe for it
thanks
for having me on this podcast
but it's vape culture but cultures of a
c-x-l-t-r-e
what culture rape culture wave yeah okay
because i maybe
on instagram on instagram such a british
thing in it wavy
okay cool at my nationality
american thing yeah it's wave culture on
instagram thanks for having me paul yeah
thanks for coming
back to eileen i'm just
uh eileen
s h e-i-l-e-n-s-h-i 32 on instagram and
on venmo if you want to you know send me
some cash money
[Music]
you know it's okay only women can say
this stuff you know yes
i hope you guys
what is it um
you know just so show her social media
out to everyone every one of your
friends like you know she says pretty
good like
what is it
like post or whatever
i get a little anxious go ahead for all
okay guys um if you haven't already
subscribe to the channel guys if you're
watching now and you haven't subscribed
to the channel we have beef okay like